bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi sur l'agriculture un texte
dont l'objectif est de prendre le virage
de
l'agroécologie alors avec nous pour en
parler cet après-midi Didier Guillaume
sénateur socialiste de la Drome et
rapporteur du texte ici au Sénat samedi
le Sénat reconnu le 20 comme faisant
partie du patrimoine français est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous tenait
particulièrement à cœur oui il me tenait
ça me tenait beaucoup à cœur c'est à la
fois un symbole et une reconnaissance
c'est un symbole parce que affirmer que
la viticulture française que le vin est
un produit issu de l'agriculture mais
est un produit phare de notre de notre
économie c'est un vrai symbole qu'il
faut préserver mais mais qu'il faut
préserver qu'il faut développer qu'il
faut promouvoir et puis c'est une
reconnaissance la reconnaissance de
toutes ces femmes et des hommes qui
travaillent la Vig qui travaillent la
terre et qui font un produit qui est
reconnu dans le monde entier lorsque
vous allez à l'étranger on vous parle du
vin on vous parle du vin français et ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
fort et moi j'y tenais beaucoup et
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des sénateurs y
tenait puisque c'est un amendement et
c'est une position qui a été prise à
l'unanimité j'en suis très heureux alors
autre question qui devrait être abordée
cet après-midi c'est la question de la
place du loup les sénateurs UMP ont
voulu en faire une espèce protégée
simple qu'en est-il exactement enfin ça
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui le loup
est reconnu comme une espèce protégée
par les instances européennes la
Directive Habitat et la Convention de
Berne pourquoi parce que à l'époque il a
30 ans on considérait que le loup était
une espèce en voie de disparition moi
j'ai voulu faire évoluer le le texte et
j'ai fait voter en commission un article
supplémentaire pour dire deux choses
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous pour la
biodiversité mais le loup n'est plus une
espèce en voie de disparition le la
population de loup augmente aujourd'hui
il y a un vrai problème c'est le
problème de cohabitation entre le loup
et l'élevage et les éleveurs et le
pastoralisme et Lou peuvent même parfois
être une menace pour euh les agriculurs
bah ils sont une menace puisque moi dans
mon département euh l'année dernière
c'est plus de 400 bre qui ont été
hébergé donc ce n'est plus possible donc
moi je considère que la cohabitation
n'est pas possible entre le loup et le
pastoralisme et entre le loup et le
pastoralisme moi je choisis l'éleveur
plutôt que le prédateur c'est la raison
pour laquelle je souhaite que la France
s'engage auprès de l'Europe à relancer
la discussion sur la Convention de Berne
et sur la Directive Habitat et qu'en
attendant j'ai souhaité que le Sénat
sécurise les éleveur en disant tout
simplement un loup attaque votre
troupeau vous avez le droit à
l'autodéfense c'est ce qui sera voté cet
après-midi et qui sera dans le texte de
loi très bien merci merci à vous donc
une question qui sera discutée tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle et on se dirige
tout de suite vers la séance l'ordre du
jour appelle la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi à adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale projet de loi
d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus aux amendements identiques
numéro 321 rectifié et
542 rectifié à l'article
15 amendement 321
rectifié monsieur Cardou vous avez la
parole
oui puisque notre monsieur César est
sorti quelques minutes il m'a chargé de
présenter pour lui cet amendement donc
il vise à insérer un alinéa ainsi rédigé
après l'article 9 l'installation
d'agriculteurs ayant bénéficié d'une
formation et d'une expérience
professionnelle adéquate donc c'est un
amendement qui vise à insérer
expressément l'installation
d'agriculteur dans les nouveaux critères
permettant de déterminer entre
guillemets l'intérêt économique et
environnementale d'une opération soumise
au contrôle des structeurs Cees critères
seront pris en compteins cycle prévoit
l'article pour déterminer l'ordre des
priorités du schéma directeur régional
d'exploitation agricole ce qui semble de
bon sens puisque certains qui ont fait
ont subi ou ont fait l'effort de subir
une formation devrait être
privilégié merci chers collègues
l'amendement
rectifié madame
comment madame
ferra est-ce que vous défendez cet
amendement bien alors
défendez-le merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise à insérer
expressément l'installation
d'agriculteur dans les nouveaux critères
permettant de déterminer l'intérêt
économique et environnemental d'une
opération celle-ci soumise au contrôle
des structure ces critères seront pris
en compte ainsi que le prévoie l'article
pour déterminer l'ordre des priorités du
schéma directeur régional des
exploitations agricoles en effet avec le
texte de l'article 15 la place et la
priorité lesté à l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs dans ces articles en
vertu du contrôle des structures
actuelles se trouvera considérablement
réduite seul l'article l3311 fait encore
mention d'installation toutefois
l'objectif prioritaire celle-ci ne
deviendra qu'objectif principal le futur
article ne prévoit qu'une prise en
compte de cette objectif pour la
détermination des orientations du futur
schéma régional des exploitations
agricoles de même l'ordre de priorités
prévu au TR qui fixera entre les
différentes opérations ne garantit pas
la place de
l'installation merci chers collègu
monsieur le Président rapporteur
Guillaume vous avez la Paro mon
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues C ces deux amendements sont
sont satisfaits puisqu'ils sont dans le
dans la loi d'ors et déjà pour le
contrôle des des structures il faut
tenir compte de l'intérêt économique et
environnemental donc il nous semble que
c ces deux amendements n'amènent rien de
plus au projet de loi aussi je vous
demande de les retirer ou avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président sur les deux
amendements même avis que le rapporteur
l'objectif et c'est marqué dans les
objectifs de toute cette tous ces
critère c'est l'installation et après
une fois qu'on a fixé l'objectif
d'installation on fixe des critères on
peut pas remettre dans les critères
l'objectif de l'installation puisqueil
est par définition celui qui est
l'objectif principal donc je vous
demande par rapport à ce qui est dans le
texte de de de de considérer que c'est
pleinement satisfait les critères
viennent après pour préciser dans
l'objectif de l'installation bah quel
sont les critères qu'on prend en compte
mais on fait pas l'inverse voilà malgré
cette satisfaction bon ministérielle
monsieur Cardou oh monsieur le Président
ça me paraît pas primordial il me paraît
de bon sens de le retirer en espérant
que je vais pas m'attirer les foudre de
mon
collègue merci de votre audace madame
ferrra vous le retirez aussi bravo
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur nous passons tout de suite à
l'amendement
147 madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre il y a un
alinéa 18 qui nous inquiète un peu il
s'agit de la possibilité de pondérer les
critères alors toute adéquation est en
général bienvenu mais je vous
rappellerai le schéma banal du
développement durable souvenez-vous des
trois cercles économie sociale
environnement il est de coutume de les
représenter d'égale taille ces trois
cercle en réalité l'économie c'est la
citrouille le social allez c'est une
orange en taille et puis l'environnement
une grosille ça pèse en général pas
lourd votre loi vient à point corriger
les choses rééquilibrer l'alinéa 18 met
en péril ce
rééquilibrage merci chers collègues
monsieur le
rapporteur je suis regret de de ne pas
partager votre argumentation madame
Blandin aussi j'ai met un avis
défavorable vous voulez supprimer les
pondérations je pense que c'est pas une
très bonne chose avis desfvorable merci
Monsieur le Ministre l'avie du
gouvernement même avis que le rapporteur
il s'agit pas de de de dire qu'il y
aurait une orange une citrouille et une
groseille il s'agit de se dire
simplement que dans les arbitrages qui
sont à faire justement parce que la
dimension environnementale la dimension
économique la dimension sociale sont des
enjeux qu'on arrive selon les projets
parce qu'il y a des projets qui sont
différents dans tous les domaines qui
sont plus environnementaux par exemple
dans le cadre de installation avec des
circuits courts qui sont plus
économiques parce que c'est une
installation dans un cadre plus général
dans des domaines que VI bille ou autre
qui sont aussi peut-être
plus sociaux parce qu'on est dans des
organisation avec derrière des
associations enfin laissons justement
les possibilités de prendre tous ces
critères en place c'est la meilleure
manière justement de les mettre dans le
débat de l'installation donc je souhaite
aussi comme l'a dit le rapporteur que le
mieux ça de retirer cet amendement il y
a pas de mauvaise intention derrière
ça merci Madame
Blandin voilà l'amendement est maintenu
le met au voie pas d'explication de vote
qui est
pour
contre abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté sur l'article 15 deux amendements
discussion commune l'amendement
691 madame
niikou monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement est un amendement
rédactionnel pour clarifier le texte de
l'alinéa 40 qui euh qui se lit de la
façon suivante pour déterminer la
superficie totale mise en valeur il est
tenu compte de l'ensemble des
superficies exploitées par le demandeur
sous quelque forme que ce soit et toute
production confondue en appliquant les
équivalences fixées par le schéma
directeur régional des exploitations
agricoles pour les différents types de
production merci l'amendement 792 n'est
pas défendu l'avis du
rapporteur avis favorable monsieur le
Président même avis monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre je
mets au voix cet amendement 691 pour
contre abstention il est
adopté sur l'article 15 toujours 13
amendements identiques le 785 rectifié
bis monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur
le Président là je vais être un tout
petit peu plus long mais il mérite
quelques explications c'est l'amendement
que nous avons présenté en commission et
qui a été accepté par la commission euh
sur le le contrôle des structures
toujours euh l'anila 52 soumet à
l'autorisation d'exploiter les mises en
valeur de terrains reçu desè saffaires
or la rédaction du projet de loi je
dirrais dire l'excellente rédaction du
projet de loi monsieur le ministre mais
conduit à étendre le nombre des
opération de rétrocession des saffaires
qui seront suivi d'une demande
d'autorisation d'exploiter en
particulier il faudra une autorisation
d'exploiter pour tous les agrandissement
la solution écrite dans le projet de loi
n'est donc pas satisfaisante à notre
avis les safaires agissent dans le
respect des objectifs du contrôle des
structures un commissaire du
Gouvernement y veille au sein des
affaires en demandant une autorisation
d'exploiter pour toutes les rétrocession
et pas seulement sur celle résultant de
l'exercice de droit de préemption on
crée une contrainte administrative
supplémentaire et non nécessaire et vous
savez que la Haute Assemblée est
toujours là pour essayer de réduire les
contraintes administratives ce risque ce
qui est écrit dans le projet de loi
serait d'allonger le délai de
réalisation des rétrocession de bienquis
à l'amiable mon amendement et
l'amendement est donc un amendement de
de simple ation il prévoit que l'avis
favorable du commissaire du Gouvernement
vaille autorisation d'exploiter pour les
mises en valeur donc on aurit donc une
seule procédure au lieu de
de merci Monsieur le Ministre même avis
très bien
expliqué
308 Monsieur
Philippe je vous remercie excusez-moi le
président de la commission prend la
parole je vous passe la parole
ensuite c que pour la simplification de
la discussion est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
se borner aux amendements qui concernent
l'alinéa
52 ça simplifierait parce qu'après on
passe au 53 et cetera et je crois que on
gagnerait en
efficacité on sa donc en deux nous
sommes sur les l'alinéa 52 d'abord donc
il y a deux amendements identiques sur
cette alinéa 52 le 308 qui est présenté
par Monsieur Philippe
B monsieur le président le le rapporteur
le président Guillaume a fort bien
défendu l'amendement identique qu'il a
présenté le ministre a déjà donné un
avis favorable je suppose que ces deux
interventions entraîneront l'adhésion
générale du Sénat et donc je dispense le
Sénat de davantage
d'explication alors le 363 rectifié
monsieur Collin oui euh je confirme
effectivement que cet amendement a été
excellemment défendu par le rapporteur
précisait quand même que cette rappelit
que cette proposition devrait pas poser
de problème dans la mesure où les
saffaires et le contrôle des structures
agissentans un cadre juridique et
réglementaire tourné vers l'intérêt
général au service d'une même politique
et d'ailleurs aucun contentieux n'a été
introduit à l'en compte des projets
d'attribution par session ou par
substitution au motif de la
méconnaissance par les affaires des
dispositions relatives au contrôle des
structures agricole et j'ajouterai que
les décisions prises par les saffaires
passent par le filtre des commissaires
du gouvernement à après avis des comités
techniques enfit la rédaction actuelle
dans la mesure où l'acte de rétrocession
doit être subordonné à l'obtention par
l'exploitation bénéficiaire d'une
autorisation préalable risque de
ralentir la procédure de rétrocession et
aussi générer un contentieux posant pour
un même bien les candidats à
l'exploitation à ceux seulement
intéressés par une mise en valeur c'est
dire c'est un excellent amendement que
je vous invite à
adopter merci Monsieur Collin cher
Président Monsieur alors sur ces deux
amendements identiques oui sur ces deux
amendements je demande le retrait des
deux puisqu'ils sont satisfaits par
l'amendement que nous avons voté en
commission qui est un peu plus
large même avis il
est Monsieur Collin vous retirez donc il
est retiré donc il me reste l'amendement
de la commission à mettre on VO on le
prend tout de suite la suite 53 59 alors
le 70 rectifié bis oui parce qu'il
modifie oui oui qui le défend c'est moi
monsieur le Président si vous le voulez
bien monsur oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à alléger la
procédure
d'autorisation dès lors que il s'agit de
situation particulière c'est-à-dire que
le déclarant satisfait aux conditions de
capacité d'expérience professionnel que
le bien est libre de loocation au jour
de la déclaration que le bien est détenu
par un
on sait que le régime d'autorisation est
souvent lourd et que pour avoir la
réponse il faut beaucoup de temps et
bien cette suggestion propose d'alléger
de dès lors qu'il s'agit de conditions
particulière c'est l'objet de cet
amendement merci le 545 tombe le
557 rectifié madame ferra
i monsieur le Président c'est amendement
de
coordination
merci
500 93
tombe
314 3 monsur C monsieur César c'est vous
qui le
présentez il est présenté il est
présenté le 546
tombe le 547 tombe
le 148 madame
Blandin la dérogation accordé au bien
famille en terme de contrôle des
structures peut avoir un effet pervers
pour les preneurs en place exerçant
leurs droits de reprise des
propriétaires mettent à mal la viabilité
des exploitations de leurs preneurs
exerçant sur les terres de plusieurs
propriétaires à défaut de réétablir le
contrôle des structures sur les
transferts des biens de famille il
faudrait à minima permettre au preneurs
évincé de défendre son projet et son
exploitation via une présentation des
projets des preneurs et repreneurs
devant la CDOA pour avis de cette
dernière qui est souveraine sur la base
du schéma directeur régional des
exploitations agricoles c'est l'objet de
cette
amendement merci chers collègues alors
monsieur le rapporteur oui l'avis de la
commission sur les amendements relatifs
à l' ligéat 5 monsieur le le le
président alors celui de Monsieur revet
régime dogatoire pour la reprise des
biens de famille l'article 15 qui a créé
des un dispositif un peu plus sévère
votre amendement propose de le rendre un
peu moins sévère or enfin moi il me
semble que si on veut un contrôle des
structures suffisamment suffisamment
fort et lutter contre l'agrandissement
excessif il faut il faut que ce contrôle
des structures soit plus fort donc j'ai
misis un avis défavorable c'est dans le
casre familial hein l'amendement de bon
madame ferra l'amendement madame ferra
c'est les amendements traditionnels de
remplacer la région par le Département
donc j'y mets à nouveau un avis
défavorable sur monsieur César le 314 je
demanderai de de le retirer ça a déjà ça
a déjà été vu en en commission il nous
semble que le souhait des auteurs est
satisfait par le 4e alinéa de cette de
cet article et celui de Madame Blandin
euh oui nous l'avons déjà vu en
commission celui-là je vous demanderai
le retrait sinon
défavorable monsieur le
ministre moi je
vais dire simplement que je suis bien
sûr d'accord avec ce que vient dire le
rapporteur quelle est l'idée qui a
derrière tous ces amendements c'est
d'essayer de réduire un peu le la
possibilité d'avoir une action publique
en particulier quand ça concerne les
biens de famille de la saffaire et
ensuite du contrôle des structures je
vous demande de bien bien considéré
parce que ça c'est très important que si
on renforce le rôle des affaires avec
les gouvernances que vous savez puisque
on en a discuté déjà on est bien là avec
un seul objectif un seul objectif c'est
pas de faire quelques contrôle que ce
soit ou d'avoir des envies d'empêcher
les transmissions les donations la
question des biens publics mais c'est
simplement de garder en tête l'objectif
de l'accès au fonciers pour les jeunes
agriculteurs c'est tout c'est le qu'on a
fixé au safair qu'elles vont mettre en
œuvre c'est à partir du moment où les
safaires font des opérations les
questions de contrôle de structure on
est simplement là pour bien fixer les
objectifs et il faut pas y voir après
tout un tas de problèmes que je sens
poindre au travers de ces amendements on
garde le principe l'objectif c'est
favoriser l'accès au fonciers éviter que
des agrandissement se fasse sans qu'on
puisse rien y faire mettant en cause
ensuite la capacité que des jeunes
pourront avoir à
s'installer merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur César oui monsieur le Président
merci moi j'ai bien attentendu le la la
présentation qui est faite par Monsieur
le
Ministre l'objectif c'est d'installer
des jeunes agriculteurs et c'est ça
l'objectif et je crois que c'est le rôle
essentiel de la Safire d'installer des J
et je crois qu'il faut faut pas revenir
dessus c'est c'est un rôle qui a été
déterminé par la loi de 1960 qui a été
présenté par Monsieur Pisani qui était
ministre à l'époque à l'époque et nous
avons tous mémoire du travail qu'il a
fait du travail excellent sous
l'autorité du général de Gaul faut pas
l'oublier un Gauliste peut le dire il va
il le dit donc pour autant pour autant
je suis tout à fait favorable à ce que
je retire mon amendement hein et donc je
suis favorable à ce que les saffaires
continuent à installer les jeunes
agriculteurs c'est fondamental pour
l'avenir de notre
pays merci l'amendement 314 est
retiré je n'ai pas d'autre explication
de vote je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 785 rectifié bis de
monsieur Guillaume qui est
favorable contre abstention il est
adopté cela fait tomber le 70 rectifié
bis monsieur le rapporteur nous sommes
d'accord et le 7 757 rectifié et donc il
me reste le 148 présenté Parame Blandin
qui est maintenu retiré il est
retiré
discussion commune sur l'article 15
toujours l'amendement
146 madame
Blandin les formes sociétaires
deviennent majoritaires elles sont quand
même passées de 70000 en 2010 à
126000 en 2013 or depuis la loi busro de
2006 elles échappent au contrôle des
structures puisque que celui-ci ne
s'exerce que pour une augmentation de
surface selon l'unité de référence
définie au niveau départemental cette
exonération du contrôle pour les formes
sociétaires permet des agrandissements
déguisés par la création de société dont
l'associé vendeur de ces terr se retire
au bout de quelques années ce sont ainsi
75 à 80 % des agrandissant qui échappe
ainsi au contrôle et concurrence
l'installation par cet amendement nous
souhaitons favoriser l'installation donc
renforcer le contrôle sur ces mouvements
sociétaires merci le 543 tombe et donc
monsieur le rapporteur en effet sur 146
merci monsieur le Président nous
souhaitons tous renforcer le contrôle
des structure c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite mettre un avis
défavorable à votre à votre amendement
dans la mesure où établir ce qui avait
été supprimé en 2006 et si ça avait été
supprimé en 2006 c'est qu'il y avait
sûrement des raisons c'était impossible
à vérifier ben peut-être de mauvaise
raisons mais à part du moment on avait
on arrivrivait pas à à faire ce contrôle
là c'était pas utile et à l'époque le
législateur a dû faire cela ce contrôle
s'avérrait complexe aussi l'extension du
contrôle des structures pour tout
franchissement du seuil de 50 % de
participation au capital d'une
entreprise agricole ne paraît pas
souhaitable je propose pas qu'on y
revienne donc celleid dé favorable merci
monsieur le ministre
oui débat qu'on a eu monsieur le madame
la sénatrice plutôt
déjà longuement à l'Assemblée nationale
autant nous sommes favorables à ce que
ce contrôle s'exerce de manière plus
stricte plus coordonnée par rapport à ce
qui avait été la loi de 2006 qui avait
largement reculé sur le sujet autant il
y a un moment ensuite où il faut
justifier quand même par rapport à ce
qui
la vie normale deschanges dans des
formes sociétaires le fait que la
saffaire puisse intervenir à priorie
sachant que les modifications qui
peuvent être opérées auraient des
conséquences en terme d'agrandissement
et remettra en cause l'installation si
c'est pas le cas si c'est à l'intérieur
et que ça représente pas 100 % départ
très difficile d'être dans un contrôle
systématique parce qu'à ce moment-là on
a d'abord la difficulté de pouvoir le
suivre et puis c'est vraiment de manière
indirecte l'idée que les saffaires
imposeraient à des sociétaires des
associés ce qui n'est pas possible non
plus c'est pour ça que on va pas aussi
loin j'ai déjà eu le débat c'est un vrai
débat mais à force de vouloir tout
réglementer on finit par ne pas le faire
au fond parce que là on est à la limite
de ce qui est le droit de propriété de
ce qui est le choix que peut faire des
agriculteurs par rapport à à leurs
associés et donc là je suis pas
favorable à cet amendement pour ces
raisons-là
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement monsieur
revet pardon merci Monsieur
Président je vais m'abstenir sur ce cet
amendement monsieur le ministre je pense
qu'il faut quand même qu'on regarde les
choses de près on partage comme vient de
le dire mon collègue gérard César sur le
fait et et j'avais j'ai pas pu le
défendre mais déposer un amendement dans
ce sens-l lorsqueon a traité des la
action des affaires et bien entendu il
faut
privilégier l'installation de jeunes on
en a besoin et il faut tout faire et ça
doit être et il faut le rappeler la
priorité des organismes qui ont à
traiter du sujet et notamment les les
saffaires mais monsieur le ministre il
existe des situations et j'ai été
interpellé nous sommes dans une période
où il y a des foir concours et autres à
plusieurs reprises par par des
responsables professionnels parce que il
il existe des systèmes juridiques où
finalement personne ne peut intervenir
ni la Safa ni euh les les services
préfectoraux et ça on ne prend pas en
compte et en général ce sont pour des
surfaces extrêmement importantes qui
vont bien au-delà de l'installation d'un
jeune ou de ce que est nécessaire pour
pour pouvoir comment dirais-je avoir une
exploitation euh euh économiquement
viable et ça apparemment on ne traite
pas monsieur le ministre et je voudrais
que quand même on le regarde de près
parce que euh il y a des gens qui ont
des moyens extrêmement importants mais
qui ont une forme juridique qui fait
qu'ils sont exenté euh de la déclaration
de l'autorisation du passage en
commission et autres je pense monsieur
le ministre qu'il faut regarder ça de
près merci monsieur le
ministre
c'est bien pourquoi on a voté un certain
nombre de mesures qui font que dans le
schéma régional que va mettre en que
vous mettre en application les affaires
tout ce qui va être des mouvements qui
conduiraient à des agrandissement
au-delà d'un certain seuil sera regardé
par les saaires c'est bien tout l'enjeu
de toutes les discussions tous les
amendement qu'on a mis en place donc ce
que vous évoquez comme des
agrandissements massifs qui échappent à
tout contrôle c'est pas vrai avec ce que
nous avons voté et ce que nous allons
voter il y aura un contrôle qui sera
fait par les saffaires et le contrôle
ensuite des structures le commissaire au
gouvernement en particulier puisque ça a
été dit par DJ Guillaume dans
l'amendement qui a été présenté par la
Commission pourra se saisir directement
au sein des affaires pour alerter
lorsqu'il y a des agrandissements donc
sur cette question précise que vous
évoquez monsieur le sénateur on apporte
les réponses que vous souhaitez
c'est-à-dire qu'on puisse
intervenir mes chers collègues je mets
au voix cet amendement 146 qui est
favorable qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est
pas adopté amendement
322 monsieur
césarement un amendement rédactionnel
puisque après le mot refuser je je
propose notamment parce qu'il y a toute
une liste après euh et oui je sais je
sais que notamment vous adorez monsieur
le rapporteur mais c'est comme les
rapports ça mais là c'est pas un rapport
c'est notamment parce qu'il y a des cas
il y a des cas de figure
voilà merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur bien joué monsieur
César non c'est pas uniquement
rédactionnel parce que si on remplace la
liste fermée par notamment alors c'est
plus une liste et on pourrait en avoir
que quelques-uns donc je peux pasmettre
mettre un avis favorable je vrais même
mettre un avis défavorable non votre
votre votre amendement est purement
rédactionnel puisqu'il met le mot
notamment mais ça a des conséquence
derrière tout amendement étant par
définition rédactionnel monsieur le
ministre très juste monsieur le
Président donc au-delà du fait qu'il est
rédactionnel c'est
défavorable monsieur César non j'ai
crois que vous bien je met au voit ce
322 non il est retiré il est retiré
l'amendement
621 monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement nous souhaitons renforcer le
respect des exigences posées par
l'article 15 du projet de loi en effet
en l'état actuel du le projet de loi
précise que l'autorisation
administrative d'exploiter ne peut pas
être refusé alors même que les
conditions posées par le schéma
directeur régional ne serait pas
respecté dans le cas où il n'existe pas
d'autres candidats à la reprise de
l'exploitation concerné ni preneur en
place il paraît donc au contraire
nécessaire d'être ferme sur les
objectifs à respecter et en particulier
celui d'éviter des agrandissements
excessifs c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons de supprimer cette dérogation
et de refuser l'autorisation d'exploiter
dans l'attente des
candidatures merci Madame ger main
monsieur
monsieur le Président Madame Gontier
main ce texte veut aussi souple autant
que faire se peut et donc vous voulez
supprimer cette souplesse qui comme
l'aurait dit la paliss conduirait une
rigidité donc je propose qu'on reste la
souplesse je vous demande de le retirer
ou deettre je mettrai un avis
défavorable monsieur le
ministre même avis que le rapporteur
avec juste un ajout si on allait
jusqu'au bout de cette logique lorsqu'il
y a un repreneur et pas d'autres on
aurait donc dans ce cas parce que pour
des raisons X ou Y la possibilité de
refuser que ce repreneur puisse
reprendre ce qui par rapport à
l'objectif d'intérêt général qui est de
favoriser le fait que les terres soient
exploité reviendrait à être en
contradiction avec cet objectif comment
on ferait s'il y a pas de candidat et
s'il y en a qu'un seul pour dire bien
non on ne peut pas et on vous le donne
pas le problème du contrôle des
structures comme le rôle des saaires
c'est des d'arbitrer lorsqu'il y a
plusieurs repreneurs en faveur de ce qui
va favoriser l'installation et
renouvellement de génération c'est ça
l'objectif et là on sera en
contradiction avec l'objectif donc je
peux pas comme l'a dit monsieur le
rapporteur être favorable à votre
amendement l'amendement est maintenu
l'amendement est retiré amendement 692
madame
niikou monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement est un amendement de
cohérence avec la alinéa 73 modifié par
la commission des affaires économiques
du Sénat en effet la cet alinéa la durée
pendant laquelle l'administration peut
procéder à un examen de la demande
d'autorisation lorsqu'elle constate une
diminution du nombre d'emplois a été
allongée de 2 ans passant de 3 dans la
proposition initiale à 5 ans il convient
donc d'allonger d'autant la durée
pendant laquelle les saffaires doivent
transmettre à l'administration les
informations sur les sessions de part
social qui font partie des informations
dont la administration doit disposer
pour pouvoir assurer ce réexamen cette
durée doit ainsi passer de 4 à 6
ans merci monsieur le rapporteur même
avis je mets au voix le 692 qui est pour
contre abstention
adopté discussion commune l'amendement
247 rectifié bis n'est pas
défendu le
375 monsieur mon
Collin il veut me déstabiliser monsieur
le
rapporteur je crois que cet amendement
est assez clair dans son objet et
j'allais je m'apprê à dire notre
collègue vient d'en défendre en
identique pour ma part il est le fruit
d'une inquiétude que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'exprimer dans ce même esprit lors de
la discussion de l'article 13 j'ai la
crainte peut-être à tort me direz-vous
que c couperai limite l'emploi plutôt
qu'il ne l'encourage je vous rassure je
n'ai pas une vision libérale des choses
mais on connaît la partic particularité
du secteur agricole il est soumis à
trois types d'aléas qui peuvent en outre
se cumuler des de marché des aléas
climatiques des aléas sanitaires et
ceux-ci peuvent malheureusement
entraîner une chute brutale d'activité
c'est une évidence je crois pour tout le
monde pour autant c'est vrai que le
délai aboutissant à la remise en cause
du droit d'exploitation dans le cas du
constat d'une baisse de l'emploi a été
allongé de 3 à 5 ans après examen du
texte par nos collègues de la commission
mes collègues ont fait là d'ailleurs
preuve d'une extrême sagesse monsieur le
Président en permettant une plus longue
visibilité pour mieux rapprécier
l'évolution de l'exploitation je me
range donc à l'avis de notre rapporteur
et du ministre qui vont s'exprimer et je
retire cet amendement qui était plutôt
une alerte je vous
remercie cher président puisque votre
amend est retir on va pas demander au
rapporteur de s'exprimer si vous en êtes
d'accord l'amendement 491 rectifié et
n'est pas défendu il reste
788 de monsieur
Guillaume
le
rédactionnel et le 150 monsieur l'abbé
madame monsieur
l'ABB oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues le contrôle
des structures doit permettre lutter
contre l'agrandissement excessif
favoriser l'installation et la
consolidation des exploitations mais
mais il doit aussi permettre de
maintenir et développer l'emploi
agricole les formes sociétaires sont
utilisées par certains pour masquer des
agrandissements aussi est-il utile de
pouvoir évaluer ex poste la légitimité
du projet porté dans le cadre sociétaire
pour s'assurer que la société n'a pas
servi d'écran à un agrandissement pour
se faire il est utile de suivre
l'évolution de l'emploi salarié dans la
dite société seulement il s'agit
seulement d'une possibilité offerte à
l'autorité administrative autant dire
qu'à moins d'une mobilisation syndicale
extrêmement forte il risque bien de ne
rien se passer aussi s'agissant d'une
baisse constatée de l'emploi agricole il
nous apparaît essentiel que le réexamen
de l'autorisation d'exploiter soit
systématique merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
Monsieur Collin a retiré son son
amendement qui voulait supprimer le
réexamen monsieur monsieur Labé veut
l'obliger moi je veux rester dans une
position d'équilibre d' avoir la
possibilité de réexaminer le contrôle
des structures pour le cas où il y
aurait une baisse d'emploi donc un avis
retrait ou défavorable même avis c'était
même avis merci alors monsieur l'abbé
cet appel pressent retrait vous y
répondez
ou bon toujours dans le cadre de la
recherche d'équilibre je vais le retirer
mais il n'en sera pas de même pour mes
mes futurs amendements bien je mets donc
donc on voit le
788 mes chers collègues l'amendement
rédactionnel 788 qui est pour contre
abstention il est
adopté le 151 monsieur l'abbé c'est à
vous
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'article 3317
porte sur les sanction possible en cas
de non respect de la réglementation
structure cette sanction s'élève au
maximum à 914,70 € par hectare 9
centimes au mètre carré ce que je ne
suis pas sûr de trouver tellement
tellement dissuasif pour être efficace
il faudrait que le préfet puisse retenir
les aides publiques sur les terres
objets du litige ce serait déjà beaucoup
plus efficace que la procédure actuelle
rappelons que la règle selon laquelle la
sanction administrative ne s'applique
pas aux aides dites européennes les DPU
n'est pas fondée en droit elle s'appuie
sur une réponse ministérielle faite vers
958 16 et jamais soumise depuis un
jugement de la juridiction
administrative nous proposons donc de
rétablir pour le préfet la faculté de
retenir les aides publiques sur les
terres objet de l'infraction je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur l'abbé il me semble que
votre amendement est totalement
contraire aux règles européennes euh les
règles les aides de la PAC sont soumises
aux règles européennes et pas au règles
françaises donc je peux pas émettre un
avis favorable je peux même émettre un
avis défavorable si vous retiriez
pas monsieur le ministre bon on avait
été prévenu hein monsieur l'abbé mais
quand
même les règles européennes de
distribution des aides de la politique
agricole sont négociées à l'échelle
européenne un état ne peut pas remettre
en cause la distribution il peut se voir
d'ailleurs lui-même sanctionner
quelquefois si la distribution n'est pas
conforme aux règles européennes mais on
ne peut pas nous remettre en cause la
distribution d'aide européennes sur des
critères de règles nationales en
particulier sur des sujets comme le
contrôle des structures c'est pas
j'allais dire juridiquement possible il
y a eu d'ailleurs on me dit on m' ditque
puisque les servic juridique ont
travaillé une jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État qui a posé le principe de
l'interdiction de supprimer les aides de
la PAC à titre de sanction en matière de
contrôle des structures
elle date de on va pas donner la date
c'est VO donc les services travaill mais
avec un tout petit manquement on reverra
ça ce
soir merci monsieur ministre monsieur
l'abbé monsieur ministre je n'ai pas vu
votre papier mais je vous fais confiance
sur parole alors exceptionnellement je
vais encore retirer
celui-là merci chers collègues de cette
décision exceptionnelle la parole est
maintenant à monsieur
guillaumeieur le Président 773
clarification monsieur le ministre toi
qui on clarifie tout va bien donc
favorable je mets au voix ce
773 pour contre abstention il est adopté
et je mets au voix l'article
15 qui est pour contre abstention
l'article 15 est adopté sur
l'article
16 l'amendement 30 rectifié
bis qui le
défendsur monsieur Philippe Bas vous
êtes
signataire est-ce que vous considérez
qu'il est
défendu j'avais compris ça de votre
argumentation tout à l'heure monsieur le
rapporteur
oui euh monsieur le Président je donne
un avis défavorable à la suppression de
l'article euh un des choix du ministre
dans cette loi c'est de passer de la SMI
à laama euh cet article veut su veut le
supprimer donc j'ai mis un avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre alors
au au-delà au-delà du fait que ça serait
euh pour faire plaisir au ministre il y
a il y a un enjeu derrière c'est que
nous avons conduit des assises de
l'installation avec les j le MRJC et
toutes les organisations
professionnelles qui étaient concerné
par l'installation au bout de cette
discussion qui a duré 1 an le constat
qui a été fait et qui vaut d'ailleurs
pour l'enjeu de l'installation hors cade
familiale c'est que tout ramener en
terme d'installation à la
surface qui s'appelait minimum
d'installation c'est comme si c'était la
surface qui définissait la capacité à
installer un jeûe est apparu c'était ce
que je pensais mais globalement à toutes
les organisations professionnelles comme
quelque chose de trop limitant et on est
passé à un autre concept qui s'appelle
Lama c'est-à-dire l'activité minimum
d'assugjétissement à la
MSA pourquoi parce que on considère que
dans l'installation si je prends par
exemple des systèmes avec une
commercialisation en circuit mais avec
beaucoup de valeur ajoutée c'est pas la
surface qui compte c'est la valeur
ajoutée le revenu qu'on est capable de
dégager donc là vraiment c'est une
question de fond le Didier le rapporteur
l'a évoqué c'est pas simplement un choix
du ministre c'est une discussion qui a
eu lieu dans le cadre des Assises de
l'installation c'est vraiment un
changement mais comprenez qu'on ne peut
pas réduire l'installation et sa
possibilité uniquement à la surface
c'est trop réducteur il faut qu'on
prenne l'ensemble des capacités qu'un
jeune a à dégager du revenu c'est comme
ça qu'on réussit
l'installation je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement 30 rectifier bis qui est
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 31 rectifié bis Monsieur B
c'est un amendement de conséquence du
précédent qui a été rejeté donc je le
retire merci TR amendements identiques
le 315 i monsieur César oui merci
monsieur le Président ça c'est pas un
amendement
rédactionnel c'est donc supprimer
l'alinéa 5 pourquoi parce que nous
savons qu'il y a trois critères qui
rentrent dans l'activité minimale
d'assement donc la mise en valeur d'une
superficie égale à SM un temps de
travail au moins égal à 1200 he et un
revenu professionnel au moins égal à
l'assiette minimale d'Assurance Maladie
c'està-dire 800 SMIG donc il introduit
un critère de revenu professionnel et je
propose dans dans mon amendement que le
temps de travail qui est un critère
déclaratif et qui est tout à fait
difficile à contrôler nous nous sortions
justement de la liste des trois
conditions merci l'amendement
392 n'est pas défendu et le 523 rectifié
non
plus donc je passe au 153 présenté par
Monsieur Labé
oui pour nous la la surface minimale
pardon est un vrai frein à
l'installation or il est proposé
actuellement de ne pas prendre en
considération le temps de travail
euh si ce si le critère de surface n'est
pas respecté euh pour nous c'est une
erreur et une erreur d'ailleurs que la
MSA est prête à abandonner le critère de
surface
merci le
624 rectifiés Monsieur Le Cam Mons le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues oui
cet article 16 du projet de loi va dans
le bon sens en effet l'activité minimale
d'sugestissement évalué à partir de la
surface du temps de travail ou encore du
revenu généré par l'exploitation
agricole va permettre d'élargir le
nombre de bénéficiaires de la MSA et par
cet amendement nous vous demand donc les
heures converties s'ajoutent aux heures
du temps nécessaire à la conduite de
l'exploitation sans équivalence de
surface il est proposé donc que le
calcul du nombre d'heures se fasse en
deux
étapes merci chers collègues le 333tif
monur
C pour donc compléter par l'avis de la
commission départementale de
l'agriculture la CDOA merci le 575
rectifié n'est pas
défendu et le 550 rectifié monsieur
Tran il est
défendu le
154 monsieur l'abb
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues on compte plus
de 100000 cotisant solita solidairirees
et solitaire d'ailleurs un/4 se situe
immédiatement sous le seuil
d'affiliation en tant que chef
d'exploitation ou entreprise agricole
initialement ce statut avait été créé
pour des occupants de terres agricoles
non
agriculteursse cotise solidairement à la
MSA à la protection sociale des
agriculteurs mais de depuis ceux qui
occupent des terres pour des loisirs les
associés d'un ARL non agricole ne sont
plus soumis à cotisation la cotisation à
taux plein est élevée conduisant de trop
nombreux agriculteurs à se maintenir
dans le statut de cotisant solidaire le
projet de loi instaure l'activité
minimale
d'assuggestissement reconnaissant
l'installation progressive il serait
logique d'inscrire également une
progressivité des cotisations à sortie
des droits correspondants pour permettre
au tisan solidairire d'être réellement
reconnu indirectement cela donnerait
enfin un statut unique pour ceux et
celles qui ont choisi
l'agriculture
merci monsieur le rapporteur c'est à
vous sur l'ensemble des amendement
président merci donc l'amendement de
Monsieur César nous avons beaucoup
oui monsieur César nous avons beaucoup
parlé en en commission il nous semble
qu'il faut garder les trois critères
c'est important la surface le revenu
professionnel et la et le le temps de
travail parce que dans plein de petites
exploitations le temps de travail
permettra de vérifier la réalité des
choses donc avis défavoraable nous en
avons nous en avons parlé sur le 153 de
Monsieur Labbé alors bon lui monsieur
laabbé veut c'est l'inverse donc avis
défavorable gardons l'équilibre là
encore le 624 de Monsieur Le Cam c'est
une précision utile que vous apportez
donc avis favorable le 333 de Monsieur
César et celui de
Monsieur Tropéano qui avait été défendu
là c'est pareil vous souhaitez consulter
la c la CDOA pour fixer la la MA en fait
c'est pas la SMA la MA mais c'est pas le
rôle de la CDOA de de faire cela donc je
vois pas ce que ce que ça pourrait
amener puis il me semble que ça rajoute
encore une couche donc avis défavorable
pour les pour les deux et bon et
Monsieur l'abbé là pareil avis
défavorable le le montant des
cotisations proportionnel au niveau de
au niveau d'activité c'est pas dans cet
esprit que la loi a été écrite donc avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement avis du gouver le même
exactement que l'avis du rapporteur avec
une précision sur la question du temps
de travail si c'est vérifiable d'abord
parce que sur ce temps de travail il y a
des cotisations sociales qui sont payées
donc la MSA lorsque vous êtes
agriculteur et que vous payez des
cotisations sociales sur autant de
travail vous avez plutôt intérêt de
travailler et donc c'est vérifiable et
donc il faut garder les trois critères
c'est très important de le faire bon je
reviens pas sur la question de la CDOA
et et puis donc bah le même avis sur les
différents amendements que le
rapporteur merci je vais mettre au voix
ces différents amendements le
rectifié qui est
pour contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté
le
153 qui est
pour contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 624 rectifié
pour
contre abstention il est
adopté le
3033 rectifié et le 750 rectifié
pour
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté le
154 monsieur ce monsieur l'abé pour
contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article
16 pour contre abstention l'article 16
est adopté après l'article 16
l'amendement 63 rectifié monsieur revet
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues euh la
loi du 5 janvier
2006 avait créé le fond agricole et je
crois ne pas être étranger à cette
proposition qui avait été faite à ce
moment-là euh quel était l'objectif
monsieur le ministre c'est on on a pu et
ça a été répété euh ces jours derniers
dans les
interventions on a de plus en plus de de
jeunes qui ne sont pas forcément
originaires de l'agriculture mais qui
souhaitent S install et qui reprennent
des exploitations alors quand un fils
succède à son père l'outil de travail il
est maintenu bien sûr le le père
continue d'investir de façon à céder à
son fils un outil tout à fait
opérationnel lorsqu'un agriculteur n'a
pas de
successeur quelques années
avant son départ en retraite il ralentit
les investissements et le jeune qui
arrive après et bien est obligé
d'investir lourdement et quelquefois
peut pas le faire en créant ce qui est
l'équivalent d'un fond de commerce si
vous voulez le fond agricole l'idée
c'était de dire et bien il faut faire en
sorte que même s'il y a pas de
successeur
possible si le pardon l'agriculteur n'a
pas un fils pour reprendre il faut
l'inciter à continuer à investir et à
favoriser l'avenue et l'installation
d'un jeune c'était l'esprit de la
création du fond agricole parce que on
sait que lorsqu'il faut acquérir des
matériels neufs dans tous les domaines
ou du cheptel et autres ça devient pour
beaucoup de jeunes impossible alors
qu'en opérant de cette façon on peut
minorer d'une manière importante le coût
de l'investissement et c'est l'esprit
alors l'amendement que j'ai déposé avec
mes collègues euh c'est pour
aussi simplifier la procédure et pour
développer ce type de
transfert merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur revet là habituellement vous
voulez souvent simplifier là il me
semble que ça va alourdir un peu et et
est
complexifié ah bah l'obligation de créer
un fond agricole peut générer une charge
administrative ou ou des dépenses ou des
dépenses nouvelles pour agriculteurs si
dans votre amendement c'est une
obligation obligatoire c'est une
obligation donc j'ai met un avis
défavorable nous allons entendre ce que
va dire le ministre sur le sujet
monsieur le
ministre
M monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le
sénateur il y a 2 jours on a eu un débat
ou 3 jours sur la question de savoir
s'il fallait que un cédant quelqu'un qui
arrivve en fin d'exploitation annonce
qu'il allait arrêter l'exploitation on a
mis une date de 3 ans à l'époque vous
étiez pas favorable à ça vous voyez bien
que c'est plus efficace de faire comme
ça que de créer un fond de commerce fond
agricole qui existe d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui plus ou moins mais qui ne
marche pas j'y ajoute une mesure très
importante dans la politique
d'installation qui a été d'étendre le
contrat de génération à l'installation
agricole qui fait que on peut jusqu'à 30
ans installer un jeune en succession
d'un seior avec des des exonérations de
cotisation social qui vont avec c'est
des mesures qui sont beaucoup plus
incitatives et beaucoup plus comment
dirais-je efficaces que le fond agricole
je vois bien l'idée du fond de commerce
qui consiste à le maintenir si on veut
le cder mais on sait que ça ne marche
pas alors que là avec ces deux mesures
on a des mesures incitatives clairement
avec la déclaration de fin d'activité on
anticipe et à ce moment-là on répond à
la question que vous êtes posée donc si
je peux dire votre intention au travers
de l'amendement est déjà
satisfaite
merci je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 63 rectifié qui est
pour contre
abstention l'amendement n'est pas adopté
après l'article 16 toujours l'amendement
854 présenté par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président c'est
amendement du Gouvernement amendement
854 après l'article 16 donc cet
amendement vise à lever toute ambigué
quant au régime d'affilation du régime
social des non salariés agricoles des
entreprises c'est ça qui est important
réalisant des travaux de création
restauration et entretien des parcs et
des jardins voilà
l'objectif monsieur le rapporteur très
favorable monsieur le Président avec
monsieur lasser et baahi nous voulions
présenter cet amendement mais il y avait
un problème d'article 40 je pense que
c'est bien je pense que c'est bien que
le gouvernement a présenter cet
amendement pour permettre à ceux qui
font des travaux de massonnerie dans ces
entreprises d'être affiliés au régime
avis favorable
bien merci je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 854 qui est
pour qui est contre abstention il est
adopté à
l'unanimité après l'article 16
l'amendement 660 Monsieur Le Cam oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues il s'agit de la
question des retraite des pensions la
qualité de vie des questions d'ordre
sociétal des agriculteurs et donc par
cet amendement nous constatons que les
cotisations à l'assurance vieillesse
individuelle et à l'assurance vieillesse
agricole sont basé sur des assiettes
minimum respectifes de 800 et 600 SMIC
qui entraînent un phénomène de
surcotisation pour tous les assurés
ayant des revenus inférieurs par contre
pour les assurés ayant de gros revenus
supérieur au plafond de sécurité sociale
soit 37032 € en 2013 les prélèvements ne
s'effectuent qu'à hauteur de ce plafond
ainsi un assuré social avec un revenu
annuel de 50000 € ne cotise que sur
37032 la proposition vise donc à
rétablir la justice sociale en mettant
fin au phénomène de sous de
sous-cotisation pour les hauts revenus
en outre dans le contexte budgétaire
actuel cette proposition a également
pour conséquence dégager des montants au
compre 7 de la
MSA merci Monsieur le rapporteurur pr
chers collègues je comprends bien votre
votre argumentation mais elle doit se
placer dans le régime général et pas
uniquement au niveau de l'agriculture
quand il s'agit de supprimer le plafond
des cotisations je pense pas qu'il
faille démarrer par la loi agricole pour
l'évoquer mais je suppose que vous aurez
beaucoup d'autres occasions avec votre
groupe pour parler de ce sujet avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
oui je crois que l'argument vient d'être
évoquer ça relève du pfss hein c'est
vraiment une question sur les
déplafonnements qui pe pas trouver son
sa justification dans un débat sur une
loi
agricole je mets au voix le 660 qui est
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 59 rectifié monsieur le
Président rev oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègu
l'article 8153 en cas de la gestion des
biens indivis il soumet la conclusion ou
le renouvellement du bail rural à
l'unanimité des indivisires or de
nombreuses situations de blocage sont
constatées en pratique en l'absence de
consensus DESCO indivisires sur le choix
du preneur réformer cet article permet
de solutionner de nombreux situation
actuellement dans
l'impasse merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président je vais émettre un
double avis un avis favorable à
l'intention de Monsieur revet mais un
avis défavorable parce que c'est quand
même un cavalier législatif qui n'a pas
forcément sa place dans la loi agricole
parce qu'il y a tout un tas d'autres
articles du code qui seraient concernés
si on mettait on mettait ça notamment du
Code civil donc je demander l'avis au
ministre mais moi je suis entièrement
d'accord avec ce que vous dites mais on
peut pas le r je pense pas qu'on puisse
le rentrer dans la loi donc ah ben
peut-être le ministre vous
répondra monsieur le ministre oui même
avis on a avec les questions
d'indivision un sujet qui dépasse le
code rural mais qui va jusqu'au Code
civil donc s'il devait y avoir un
changement sur les règles de
l'indivision il faudrait en débattre
donc dans le cadre d'une loi
sur finan à mon avis ou ça oui je sais
pas bon je vous répondrai tout à l'heure
après avoir vérifié non seulement la
date de la jurisprudence précédente et
cette
question loi faille ion de la famille
peut-être donc avis défavorable oui
excusez-moi donc je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement 59 rectifié
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté après l'article 16 le
283 n'est pas défendu le 492 rectifié
n'est pas
défendu monsieur bayli nous a Monsieur
Bailli
pardon l'amendement 492
rectifié il est défendu il est défendu
avis de la commission s'il vous plaî est
défendu je vais demander l'avis du
Gouvernement avis du
gouvernement alors c'est un amendement
qui donc vise à améliorer la
constitution des liste électoral du
collège des propriétaires aux élections
des chambes d'Agriculture des tribaux
paritaires et des beaux ruraux notamment
par le transfert de fichiers par des
organismes ou administration
émessur ouais en gros ouais non ça y est
j'ai j'ai fini par parce que c'est
arrivé avec un rapporteur qui a donné au
gouvernement le le soin de répondre non
cette procédure
qui pourrait avoir son sens aurait des
conséquence en termees administratif
tellement lourde qu'elle pourrait pas
être appliqué voilà le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en l'état actuel on ne
pourrait pas pas appliquer une telle
procédure donc je suis pas favorable à
cet amendement même si il pourrait y
avoir effectivement un une intention ou
quelque chose qui pourrait être retenu
mais aujourd'hui en l'état actuel on ne
pourrait pas administrativement assurer
le suivi le transfert de l'ensemble des
informations qui sont suscitées donc je
ne suis pas favorable à cet amendement
je mets au voix cet amendement 492
rectifié monsieur Billi pour contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté 659
monsieur le Cami monsieur le
Président un rapport concernant les
polypensionnés connaissant le sort
réservé au rapport je n'insisterai pas
même si le sujet est important donc le
retiré il est
retiré l'amendement 106
rectifierat Monsieur B monsieur le
Président ceci est un amendement quel
notre groupe attache une importance
toute particulière il s'agit de retirer
du texte des dispositions qui lui ont
été ajouté celles de l'article 16 B a
que dit cet article il dit que un
registre va pouvoir être constitué qui
écartera les agriculteurs retraités et
les actifs agricoles déclaré à titre
secondaire ce registre qui va être tenu
par les services des caiss de la
mutualité sociale agricole va faire
l'objet d'une communication à
l'administration et l'administration va
pouvoir par décret en Conseil d'État
limiter les aides publiques aux
personnes aux chefs d'exploitation
inscrit sur ce registre c'est dire que
l'effet utile de ce registre c'est
d'exclure les agriculteurs retraités et
les actifs agricoles déclarés à titre
secondaire du bénéfice d'un certain
nombre d'aides ce cela nous semble être
une disposition particulièrement injuste
elle va aggraver les difficultés des
retraités agricoles dont je rappelle que
le montant moyen de leur pension de
retraite était en 2013 de 715 € par mois
par ailleurs elle va pénaliser les
petits exploitants qui ont plusieurs
activités et dont les activités
extérieures à l'activité de chef
d'exploitation sont souvent
indispensables pour compléter le
financement des investissements de
modernisation de leur exploitation et
puis elle est également contraire aux
impératifs environnementaux faut-il
rappeler que les aides de la politique
agricole commune sont conditionné au
respect d'un certain nombre d'impératifs
environnementaux dès lors que ces
exploitations agricoles ne pourront plus
bénéficier de ces aides elles n'auront
plus non plus à respecter les critères
en environnementaux qui accompagnent
l'attribution des dites aid enfin c'est
une disposition qui est tout à fait
injuste puisque les pluréactifs vont
être écartés du bénéfice de ces aides
agricoles du fait de l'existence du
registre alors que un certain nombre de
rentiers pourront conserver la qualité
de chef d'exploitation et parfois
d'exploitation extrêmement importante et
continuer ainsi à bénéficier
d'aide publique et d'aide de politique
agricole commune extrêmement importante
alors même que ces petits exploitants
agricoles en serait injustement
privé merci monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur le Président chers collègues je
ne comprends pas cet amendement puisque
toute la profession agricole Demande
l'instauration d'un registre et je
soutiens la profession agricole par
contre où vous avez raison c'est que
aujourd'hui à l'étape où on en est ce
jour le registre agricole exclut trop de
catégories c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai proposé un amendement en commission
qui a été accepté à l'unanimité et qui
va permettre de faire rentrer dans le
registre les retraités d'autres régimes
les plus réactif pour l'élargir au
maximum et faire en sorte que personne
ou quasiment personne n'en soit exclu et
c'est pour ça que je vous demanderai
bien de vouloir retirer votre amendement
où j'émettrai un avis défavorable parce
que c'est vraiment une demande de la
profession et nous allons améliorer les
choses dans la discussion de cet
après-midi monsieur le
ministre sur ce débat qui est un débat
extrêmement sensible et important la
précaution que j'avais prise à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de déposer
un amendement gouvernemental qui
admettait le principe du registre et il
y avait eu d'ailleurs dans l'opposition
des remarques qui avaient été faites et
j'avais dit que avec les deux navettes
les deux lectures on verrait au fur à
mesure qu'on avancerait le cadre dans
lequel on s'inscrirait pour ce registre
et puis sur la manière dont on gérera
demain avait bien été pris comme
précaution que dans ce débat sur la base
de ce qui avait été mis dans le premier
amendement dont vous dont on discute
aujourd'hui et avec les amendements qui
doivent le corriger que c'était en
deuxème lecture qu'on verrait en
fonction des discussion qu'on aurait
avec la profession comment on ajusterait
ce registre voire si ça posait trop de
problème comment on retirerait l'idée
même du registre le débat a eu lieu et
en particulier dans un congrès il y a
pas longtemps à Biaritz des discussions
ont eu lieu on a eu des discussions avec
l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles et les amendements
proposés par le rapporteur comme par le
gouvernement pour
modifier la liste et les critères qui
intègrent les agriculteurs dans ce
registre sera fait que ça soit pour les
retraités que ça soit pour les
cotisations solidaire que ça soit pour
les chefs d'exploitation salarié demande
qui nous a été faite on va intégrer
l'ensemble de ces éléments restera à
régler le deuxième problème c'est qui
gère et gérera ce registre là-dessus des
demandes sont assez claires en
particulier de la part des chambres
d'agriculture ou comme c'était le cas au
niveau de l'amendement que j'avais
présenté on l'avait renvoyé à la MSA
pour que les choses là aussi soient
parfaitement transparentes
pour régler ce problème de la gestion on
va saisir la acnil avant toute chose
pour que le régistre et donc les
fichiers qui vont avec on a un avis
clair pour pouvoir savoir ensuite à qui
on donnera cette gestion donc la gestion
n'est pas encore décidée mais ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse ici en première lecture
au Sénat c'est d'améliorer le registre
lui-même dans une idée toute simple
comme l'a dit le rapporteur trouver un
consensus large avec l'ensemble des
organ ation professionnelle c'est ce qui
est en train de se faire et donc je vous
propose d'avancer avec en suivant les
propositions du
rapporteur merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur Philippe B monsieur le
Président je maintiens mon amendement
car j'estime que les explications donné
par le ministre comme par notre
rapporteur justifie de renvoyer à des
études plus approfondies l'adoption de
ce
registre merci je vais donc mettre au
voix cet amendement sans quater qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 524
rectifié n'est pas défaut madame fer
pardon merci monsieur le Président et
d'ailleurs puisque je suis la première
de cette longue liste je vais me
permettre de vous le lire dans son dans
son intégralité de manière à ce que vous
l'ayez à l'esprit si d'aventure vous
aviez perdu quelques quelques précisions
voilà mes chers collègues nous abordons
un article très important pour
l'organisation de la profession agricole
et dont l'impact est essentiel pour les
aides publiques qu'il perçoivent lors de
l'examen en commission nous avions déjà
abordé cette question et déposer cet
amendement il y avait une vraie
différence de point de vue entre le
rapporteur et nous c'est cet article
résulte d'un choix politique tout est
respectable mais il incarne la vision
que le Sénat veut donner de la
profession
d'agriculteur nous devons donc définir
ce qui est pour nous un agriculteur qui
tient à jour le répertoire des actifs et
donc au final qui peut bénéficier des
aides publiques cet amendement apporte
des critères plus proches des activités
agricoles pour définir les actifs il
prévoit également que ce sont les
centres de formalité des entreprises des
chambres d'agriculture qui gèent le le
registre des personnes immatriculées il
définit enfin les aides accessibles aux
personnes inscrites pour nous le texte
proposé constitue certes une première
avancée pour définir qui est agriculteur
mais ne permet pas de véritablement
qualifier les agriculteurs
professionnels en effet ce texte se
concentre sur le fonctionnement et la
gestion du répertoire et évacue la
complexité de la définition d'un
agriculteur professionnel qui ne peut se
réduire à la seule affiliation
il se borne à exclure les agriculteurs à
titre secondaire et ceux qui à un titre
quelconque bénéficient du versement d'un
avantage de retraite de plus il crée un
registre supplémentaire qui vient
s'ajouter au registre de l'agriculture
déjà en place cette définition exclut
certains agriculteurs mais conduit à
reconnaître ceux qui ne le sont parfois
pas ainsi ne serait par exemple pas
considéré comme des agriculteurs actifs
un pluactif agricul à titre secondaire
dont les revenus extérieurs excéderaient
ses revenus agricoles alors même qu'il
participe au développement du territoire
ou un agriculteur monoactif ayant exercé
une activité dans un autre régime avant
de s'installer et demandant comme tout
Français à faire valoir ses droits à la
retraite dans ce régime à l'inverse
serait considéré comme agriculteur actif
tout agriculteur quel que soit son âge
confiant la gestion de sa ferme à un
entrepreneur de travaux ou un
agriculteur pluriactif disposant d'une
exploitation importante dont il délègue
la gestion et dégageant des revenus
supérieurs à ceux procurés par son
activité extérieur l'objet de cet
amendement monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues est donc de définir
l'agriculteur non pas pour exclure mais
pour reconnaître les agriculteurs queles
que soient les modalités d'exercice de
leur métier cette définition ouverte
doit se baser sur la responsabilité et
le caractère professionnel de l'exercice
du métier dès lors il est proposé que
soit reconnu comme agriculteur toute
personne physique qui développe un
projet d'entreprise sur sa ferme quelle
qu'en soit la taille le statut juridique
ou l'affiliation sociale dès lors
qu'elle exerce directement ou par
l'intermédiaire d'une société une
activité agricole qu'elle possède la
maîtrise de la majorité du capital de
l'exploitation qu'elle dispose d'un
diplôme ou d'une expérience
professionnelle et enfin qu'elle réalise
un volume d'activités significatif
indépendant du seuil d'assugettissement
les personnes seront cul au même titre
que tous les agriculteurs sur le
registre de l'agriculture lequel
mentionnera leur qualité d'agriculteur
professionnel et notre amendement
prévoit que le bénéfice de certaines
aides publiques pourra être réservé aux
agriculteurs
professionnels merci chers
collègu l'amendement
393 n'est pas défendu
306 monsieur le Président César oui
merci monsieur le Président en réalité
François vient de défendre avec beaucoup
d'énergie et de compétences cet
amendement je n'y reviens pas mais ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que
nous sommes dans un souci de
simplification partout et le fait que ce
soit la chambre deculture qui tienne le
registre des actifs agricole me paraît
une bonne mesure c'est pas parce que je
suis un ancien président de chambre
culture que je dis ça mais c'est pour
vous dire que monsieur le Président que
aujourd'hui il faut être dans la
simplification et le fait que ça soit
les chambresculture qui tiennent le le
registre en même temps que le registre
de de de formalité des entreprises CFE
me paraît être une mesure tout à fait
intéressante c'est
vrai merci monsieur le rapporteur
demande la parole il là oui monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues j'ai
hésité un instant tout à l'heure et
c'est allé trop vite à donner un avis
favorable à l'amendement de Monsieur bas
et si c'était à refaire je donneraiis un
avis favorable comme ça vous auriez
supprimé le registre ah ben si
l'amendement de Monsieur B la
suppression du registre c'est ce que
vous avez voté et la majorité du Sénat a
voté contre et je le regrette je le
regrette finalement parce que là nous
allons passer je le regrette dans le
dans le débat parlementaire parce que là
nous allons passer maintenant une
dizaine une douzaine d'amendements à
dire F plus de ceci plus de cela et
notamment la position de Monsieur César
que je partage va vous dire mieux je
suis d'accord avec vous mais on a trouvé
quand même encore un point d'équilibre
en commission et il a été entendu avec
la profession que les choses n'étaient
pas mû qu'il fallait attendre la vie de
laacnil quand même c'est pas rien
l'acnil il y a un registre qui vient de
se faire retoquer il y a quelques
quelques semaines pour voir comment on
avançait et l'accord qui a été passé
avec la profession c'était de dire au
Sénat on vote le
registre le gouvernement fait un
amendement c'est pas de mon ressort vu
avec la profession la Commission a fait
un amendement pour élargir au maximum
c'était le souci de Monsieur monsieur
bas tout que les pluréactifs les
retraités d'autres régimes et cetera
puissent rentrer dans le dans le dans le
registre donc là on va on va écouter
l'ensemble des des amendements mais vous
savez très bien qu'on va donner des avis
défavorable à tous pour en rester à
l'accord passé avec la profession de
deux amendements liés au registre et les
négociations que mènera le ministre ça
c'est pas de notre sort avec le la
profession pour arriver en deème lecture
avec un registre qui pourra peut-être
aller si des choses sont levées qui
pourra peut-être aller au chambre
d'agculture ou pas donc je voulais le
dire là nous allons continuer monsieur
le Président excusez-moi nous allons
continuer la discussion mais je voulais
vous dire vraiment dans la transparence
la plus complète nous l'avions évoqué en
commission comment nous avions abordé le
le
sujet peut-être tout à l'heure on a
d'autres amendements et dans les
explications de vote monsieur le
Président César là je passe à
l'amendement 3 355 rectifié le président
Collin euh merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la création d'un registre des actifs
agricoles a été très attendu par les
organisation professionnelle
l'amendement gouvernemental à
l'Assemblée nationale a donc constitué
monsieur le ministre une première
réponse et je m'en félicite elle mérite
toutefois d'être complétée pour
l'agriculture la purriactivité devenue
incontournable ça a été dit en
particulier dans le sud de la France
dans mon département le tarngaron on
comptabilisé en 2010 entre 15 et 17 % de
pluéactif dans la population totale des
chefs d'exploitation et par ailleurs
au-delà des chefs d'exploitation qui ont
plusieurs
activités dont l'une au moins est
agricole il faut prendre en compte les
retraités les inactifs qui ont une
activité d'appoint dans l'agriculture
tout le monde le sait cette diversité
des personnes qui s'ajoute à celle des
différentes formes et statuts des
exploitations nécessite une définition à
la fois précise et suffisamment
englobante c'est crucial notamment pour
la question de l'éligibilité aux aides
agricoles tant nationale que la Pact et
c'est pourquoi cet amendement propose
une autre définition du registre pour
n'exclure personne mais compte tenu des
nombreux amendements poursuivants le
même objectif avec cependant une
rédaction différente je me rangerai très
volontiers derrière la meilleure
formulation pour la puractivité agricole
voilà le sens de cet engagement je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président le
248 rectifi n'est pas
défendu 249 rectifié non plus et le 155
monsieur
laabé monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la création du
répertoire des actifs agricoles ça a été
dit é est attendu depuis longtemps et
c'est donc une bonne chose euh puisque
dans les rangs de cette assemblée on se
positionne nous écologistes
souhaitons sommes attachés au
rattachement à la MSA qui détient les
informations nécessaires à son à son
élaboration reste que les critères de
définition de la population agricole
dite professionnel que l'Union
européenne rappelle devoir être objectif
et non discriminatoire tel que formulé
pour le moment sont incl deux catégories
les entrepreneurs salariés associés et
les ctisans solidaires qui feront
l'objet d'un prochain amendement les
agriculteurs professionnels engagés dans
ces coopératives d'activités et d'emploi
agricole sont donc considérés comme des
salariés déjà inscrits à la MSA et
pouvant faire la preuve de leur statut
d'associé ils peuvent facilement être
identifiés par la MSA pour être
répertoriés dans le registre je
remercie 554 rectifiés
madame
fra merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues vous
l'avez compris il s'agit d'un amendement
de repli si notre précédent amendement
n'était pas
retenu mais permettez-moi d'insister cet
amendement a pour objet de revoir la
définition de l'agriculteur
professionnel en y apportant des
critères plus proches des activités
agricoles l'amendement ne ne modifie
donc pas la gestion du registre il
reprend juste les critères que je vous
ai énoncés tout à l'heure
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur le 790 rectifié au nom de la
commission oui alors monsieur le
Président je vais aller assez vite parce
que je l'ai je crois en grande partie
défendu tout à l'heure simplement amener
quelques quelques précisions je reviens
pas sur le le fond de ce qui a été
évoqué mais peut-être pour répondre un
peu plus à Monsieur bas sur ce que nous
proposons de faire rentrer dans le dans
le registre tous les pluriactifs
agricoles dans l'activité agricole est à
titre principal ou secondaire les
cotisants solidaires dont l'activité est
comprise entre 1/5e et une demi SMI les
nouveaux agriculteurs bénéficiant d'un
contrat d'installation progressive les
retraités non agricole d'autres régimes
ayant une activité agricole donc je
crois pas qu'on puisse enfin sauf à le
démontrer je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
mettre d'autres d'autres catégories dans
le dans le registre c'est c'est
quatre catégories supplémentaires
correspondent au souhait de la
Commission et correspondent quelque part
à ce que veul la la la profession donc
nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure le
problème de l'acnil et du fichier qui
avait été retoqué et la discussion qu'il
y a entre Chambre d'Agriculture et MSA
mais il me revient pas de trancher
maintenant c'est les négociations qui
doivent se se terminer donc moi je
souhaite donc pour la deuxième lecture
ces deux obstacles soient levés l'acnil
et puis les négociations du ministre et
puis que l'on tranche sur un un un
registre qui soit le plus large possible
qui ne qui n'exclut personne et qui
puisse être inscrit dans la
loi merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur l'abbé Le 156
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues cet amendement
s'intéresse à la 2uxè catégorie de
personnes qui seraient nécessaire
d'inscrire au régime agricole les
cotisants solidaires la synthèse publiée
en juillet 2013 par la M ça sur les
cotisants solidaires indique qu'un/art
d'entre eux sont juste immédiatement
sous le seuil d'affiliation et 7,5 % de
ces cotisants passe dans la catégorie
chef d'exploitation agricole ou
entreprise agricole montrant que le
statut cotisant solidaire est pour
beaucoup un statut transitoire étape
dans l'installation progressive il
convient de retenir comme critère la
cotisation aux accidents du travail
article L 7521 plutôt que la cotisation
aux indemnités journalières l'article L
731 351 comme c'est le cas dans la
formulation actuelle le 3e alinéa de la
définition exclut de toute manière les
retraités qui s'acquittent d'une
cotisation de solidarité et qui
n'auraient pas leur place dans le
répertoire je vous remerci merci chers
collègues le
817 vous avez votre amendement vous
aussi Monsieur le Ministre bon avec le
rapporteur on avait évoquer les deux
amendements de complément qui étaient
fait justement pour élargir la base du
registre pour les agriculteurs je vous
propose donc dans cet amendement
817 deux choses la première c'est
d'intégrer les les dirigeants salariés
d'une société objets Agricole SA sasal
coopérative de production monsieur
Lab donc j'intègre on intègre les
dirigeants salariés d'une société à
objet agricole dans lesquels il y a les
sa les les SAS les SAR ou les COP de
production agricole des gérants salariés
d'une société civile d'exploitation tion
agricole
SCEA et pour faire ça il faut qu'on
supprime un article l'article
l341 2 qui posait des conditions hein et
qui faisait que ces sociétés n'étaient
pas éligiblebl à un certain nombre
d'aides donc le registre pour qu'il soit
large ça a été dit par le rapporteur et
y ajouter ses formes sociétaires
nécessite qu'on adopte cet amendement le
817 donc pour être cohérent avec ce que
nous faisons depuis le départ sur cette
grande question du registre
nonobstant la question de la gestion qui
sera posée après saisie de laacnil avec
l'hypothèse qui a été évoquée des
chambres d'avriculture et bien il faut
qu'on avance dans la définition de ce
registre c'était l'objet de cette de de
de cette lecture en particulier au Sénat
et c'est l'objet de la proposition de
l'amendement 817 par le gouvernement qui
complète donc l'amendement qui a été
présenté tout de suite par le rapporteur
merci Monsieur le Ministre
553 rectifié madame
ferra merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le critère retenu pour exclure certains
pluactifs du Registre peut paraître trop
restrictif cet amendement propose d'en
améliorer la rédaction en évitant
notamment que ceux qui exploitent à
titre secondaire de manière non vol non
volontaire ne soit affecté par ce
critère qui ne les vise pas directement
il s'agit donc d'y déroger afin de
permettre l'inscription des agriculteurs
à titre secondaire disposant d'une
capacité professionnelle dont
l'importance de exploitation permet le
leur assugétissement en qualité de non
salarié et dont les revenus agricoles
générés représenteront au moins 30 % de
leur revenu global sauf s'ils sont
affiliés en qualité de non salarié
depuis moins de 6 ans l'amendement
permettra ainsi de réintégrer au
répertoire les actifs suivants de jeunes
agriculteurs à titre secondaire
s'installant progressivement des
agriculteurs qualifiés dont l'activité
agricole à titre secondaire et pérenne
et génère au moins 30 % de leur revenus
merci merci et dernier amendement 623
dans cette discussion commune monsieur
le oui très brièvement monsieur le
Président Monsieur ministre chers
collègues donc par cet amendement d'une
part nous sommes satisfaits de
l'élargissement actuel du registre et
nous souhaitons que le bénéfice des
aides ne doit pas être conditionné par
l'inscription à ce
registre merci bien on reprend ces
amendements de discussion commune
monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez donné en partie
votre réponse déjà partie je pour
l'ensemble des des amendements je suis
désolé d'être aussi abrupte je vais
demander le retrait ou avis défavorable
au profit de l'amendement du
Gouvernement et celui de la commission
des affaires économiques et avec les
attendus que nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure pour la mise en place pour la
deuxème lecture de la finalité de ce
registre même avis merci bien donc je
vais procéder au vote mais il y a des
explications de vote préalable monsieur
le Président César oui merci monsieur le
Président en réalité par rapport la
tenue de ce registre c'est c'est
important de simplifier ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure simplifier donc pour les
agriculteurs le fait qu' vont dans la
chambre agriculture où il y a déjà le le
document qui concerne le CFE donc je
maintiens cette possibilité mais je
m'interroge pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre excusez-moi de vous interpeller
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas vu ce ce
problème avec lacnil beaucoup plus tôt
parce que vous avez discuté à
l'Assemblée nationale de ce problème de
régistre tenu par la MSA ou par la
Chambre culture pourquoi n'avez-vous pu
saisir donc la Cline beaucoup plus tôt
merci Monsieur bailli
oui j'ai bien entendu l'avis du
rapporteur et laavis de monsieur le
ministre mais moi dans cet article 16
bissa il quelque chose qui m'interpelle
s'il reste en l'état même avec
l'amendement de de monsieur le ministre
au au 6e alinéa on dit ce répertoire est
tenu par les caises de mutualité sociale
agricole qui mobilise à cette fin les
informations à leur possession et au 10
on dit eu un décret précise les
conditions d'application du présent
article notamment les conditions dans
lesquelles l'attestation est transmise
au centre de formalité des entreprise de
la Chambre d'Agriculture alors je sais
pas moi j'ai je trouve que dans il
aurait presque mieux fallu monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président
euh dire que cet article 16 bicea ben
qu'on le on en parlait qu'on en parlait
pas qui ferait partie d'une deuxième
lecture avec une toute nouvelle
rédaction lorsqu'on savait exactement
qui allait tenir ce registre il me
semble que là il y a des incohérences et
c'est pourquoi par contre je suis assez
d'accord avec qui ce que ce registre à
quoi il doit servir je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que monsieur le
rapporteur a dit tout à l'heure en
énumérant tout ce qui doit comportter
mais je trouve que si aujourd'hui ce 16
bis A il reste dans sa rédaction que
nous avons là je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup d'incohérence c'est pour ça que
je je sais pas comment on va voter ce
serait été mieux de le de le supprimer
ce C bissas en attente bien sûr de la
deuxème lecture ou quelque chose de plus
clair ou alors est-ce que monsieur le
rapporteur va pouvoir éclairer ma
chandelle peut-être que je vous propose
on prend toutes les explications de vote
hein parce que j'ai monsieur Labé aussi
qui a demandé la
parole monsieur oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre collèguue
pour l'amendement 155 j'ai eu d'une
façon bien claire la réponse du ministre
pour les entrepreneurs salariés associés
par contre je n'ai pas bien entendu par
rapport au cotisant solidair objet de
mon second amendement je retire le
premier évidemment mais le second j'ai
besoin d'une réponse précise s'il vous
plaît merci Monsieur Philippe B pour
explication de
vote le ministre et le rapporteur ont
fait preuve de beaucoup d'humilité au
fond ils nous disent nous avons
conscience des insuffisances de cette
disposition mais nous voulons mettre à
profit la navette pour l'améliorer et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout à
l'heure l'un et l'autre se sont opposés
à l'amendement de de suppression de cet
article 16 bis A si je me souviens bien
du numéro ça doit être celui-ci oui le
16 B a euh je voudrais insister sur un
point il me paraît pas de bonne pratique
législative que de bricoler un texte
d'une assemblée à l'autre de découvrir
au fur à mesure des débats son
imperfection et je crois qu'il serait
quand même hautement préférable que nous
soyons saisis de disposition qui
auraient été pr préalablement étudié en
profondeur et non pas improvisé pour
répondre aux demandes de tel ou tel
interlocuteur aussi estimable soit-il je
voudrais souligner également que si nous
avons présenté un amendement de
suppression de cet article ça n'est pas
parce que nous sommes par principe
hostile au registre bien au contraire
l'institution d'un registre qui est
demandé par de très nombreux
agriculteurs nous paraît être un progrès
mais nous sommes en revanche tout à fait
défavorable au contenu de ce texte et
qui comportait des implications très
négatives pour des agriculteurs parmi
les plus modestes et il nous semblait
qu'il était préférable de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier alors si l'on
doit transporter d'une assemblée à
l'autre des dispositions qui tout en
étant mauvaises seraient
amélioré nous pouvons apporter notre
contribution à cette amélioration et
pour ma part je voterai certains des
amendements proposés tout en étant
très déçu de cette manière de travailler
merci chers collègues je n'ai plus
d'explication de vote monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président et
votre amendement est satisfait pour
répondre à à à Monsieur l'abbé par la
par l'amendement de de la commission et
par rapport à ce que disent monsieurs
monsieur bayi et Monsieur bass monsieur
bas pardon je c'est pas un article qui
est
mauvais c'est un article que le
processus législatif a amélioré et la
Commission le travail qui a été fait par
la commission d'ailleurs je rappelle que
ça a été unanime à la commission mais
enfin peu importe ça a été pour
améliorer cet article qui nous semblait
sur plusieurs sujets devoir lêre le
premier vous l'avez dit Monsieur bailli
c'est sur ne pas exclure des des des
gens de ce registre et nous l'avons
amélioré c'est pour ça qu'il faut me
semble-t-il voter cet article avec
l'amendement du Gouvernement et notre
amendement l'amendement du Sénat qui en
fait un article ét au fait et très clair
et il reste une chose à lever pas des
moindres cher Gérard césarm une chose
c'est qui va gérer le registre mais
attendez personne est naïf dans cette
hémicycle je crois pas vous en tout cas
monsieur peut-être vous un peu plus que
d'autres Monsieur B mais pas sûr pas sûr
donc vous savez très bien qu'il se passe
des choses ici et il se passe des choses
à l'extérieur et qu'il y a des
discussions avec la profession bon mais
on en est arrivé aujourd'hui à un stade
où le périmètre du registre le compte du
registre le fond du registre est acté et
bon le Sénat a joué son rôle il a
amélioré maintenant il reste une une un
point à lever et nous ne sommes pas à
même me semble-t-il ici dans cet
hémicycle cet après-midi de répondre à
la question de Monsieur César mais
monsieur César le sait très bien c'est
c'est normal que gérard César présente
cet amendement je le comprends tout à
fait bien mais il sait très bien qu'on
ne peut pas le voter favorablement parce
qu'il faut faire quelques vérifications
voilà donc c'est ce que je voulais dire
en réponse à à à nos collègues je pense
que le Sénat a fait du bon boulot sur ce
texte et vous pouvez tous en être fier
parce que je dirais pas qu'on vient de
loin mais il y avait des choses à
arranger et en discutant et dans les
auditions que nous avons eu avec
Monsieur bi et Monsieur lasser notamment
dans les discussions que nous avons eu
avec le le cabinet du ministre et le
ministre nous sommes aperçus que l'idée
était bonne mais qui passait à travers
des gens mais c'est ça le processus
législative législatif nous l'avons
amélioré il reste un point à régler sous
couvert de la constitutionnalité du du
euh du registre laacnil et cetera ça
nous le verrons bien je crois que le
Sénat aura fait son travail et pour
répondre à Monsieur bailli le Sénat peut
être fier d'avoir amélioré cet article
et je vous demande de voter cet article
et puis entre les deux lectures il se
passera sûrement des
choses merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre moi je voudrais
juste revenir sur la méthode je suis
euh très
clair cette question du registre n'était
pas dans la loi présenté par le
gouvernement et le ministre à
l'Assemblée nationale dans les
commissions ni même au début de la
discussion générale à l'Assemblée
nationale pourquoi vous me dites
aujourd'hui pourquoi vous avez pas saisi
tout de suite laaknil parce que c'est ce
n'était pas dans la loi c'est pas le
ministre qui avait écrit ça et qui
s'était rappelé après l'avoir écrit
qu'il fallait peut-être qu'il saisisse
lail c'est qu'on m'a demandé la
profession a demandé qu'on ouvre ce
débat sur le registre registre qui qui
avait d'ailleurs été adopté en 99 et qui
n'a jamais été mis en application qui
avait été remis en cause d'ailleurs par
la majorité qui avait changé après 2002
bon voilà ce qui se passe à partir de là
j'ai pris la responsabilité de déposer
un amendement gouvernemental qui fixait
un registre agricole donné en gestion à
la MSA dans le droit fil parce que dans
mon esprit à ce moment-là j'ai fait
cette proposition dans le droit fil de
ce qui était la
Lama l'activité minimale
d'assugjétissement quand les jeunes
s'installent l'assujettissement c'est à
la MSA donc je m'étais dit la bonne
logique c'est comme on va commencer un
processus avec l'assujétissement à la
MSA avec des nouvelles installations et
ben le registre au fur et à mesure il
sera géré par la MSA entre ce moment où
j'ai déposé l'amendement et où je le dis
les députés de l'opposition ont salué
pour la première fois une démarche d'un
ministre qui n'arrive pas en disant
voilà ce que je veux et vous pouvez am
et c'est tout ce qu'on vous demande pour
une fois que j'arrive en disant je mets
sur la table quelque chose et je
souhaite qu'au fur et à mesure du débat
on améliore la proposition si ça c'est
pas un processus qui met en
responsabilité et le ministre et les
assemblée alors là franchement on peut
pas me faire ce reproche là peut faire
beaucoup de reproches pas être d'accord
avec ce que j'ai proposé mais pas
celui-là pourquoi ça s'améliore bah ça
s'améliore comme l'a dit très bien le
rapporteur parce que en commission
économique en particulier sur la
définition du registre en fonction des
auditions que vous avez fait on a
amélioré le système il est large il
n'exclut pas parce que c'était ça qui
était le le problème de l'exclusion
derrière chacun pouvait avoir des
intentions il est large et il n'exclut
pas deuxème étape celle qui reste à
faire c'est prendre avec l'acnil pour
pour voir une fois que le registre est
fait quels sont les problèmes qui sont
posés et s'il en a et s'il en a pas et
il restera une question c'est qui sera
l'autorité de
l'argument des chambres d'agriculture
est simple dans les chambres de métiers
ce sont les chambres de métiers qui
gèrent le registre des métiers et des
artisans qui sont inscrits donc il y a
un argument extrêmement clair qui est
tout à fait recevable mais on prend le
soin de régler avec laatnil les
problèmes qui sont liés à un registre
qui est quand même important et ensuite
on a une deuxième lecture et on aura
fini entre le début où j'ai déposé un
amendement pas parce que je souhaitais
mettre ça dans le débat et dans la loi
mais parce que c'était une demande qui
était extrêmement forte et la fin des
deux lectures où on aura peaufiné
l'ensemble du dispositif et on aura à la
fin un registre avec un une autorité de
gestion et à partir de là les capacités
de définir ce qui est un agriculteur de
ce qui n'en est pas je crois qu'on aura
tous progressé et tous ensemble donc
c'est pour ça que je suis sur la même
ligne que le rapporteur le travail qui a
été fait par la Commission a débouché
sur un amendement qui prend en compte
l'ensemble demande qui était faite et ce
que nous proposons sur l'amendement
gouvernemental prend l'autre partie en
particulier sur les formes sociétaires
pour les inscrire dans le registre peut
pas je crois dans ce processus être plus
transparent plus dans le dialogue plus
dans la coconstruction avec le
Parlement
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
mettre au voix ces différents
amendements le 524
rectifié qui est
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté le
306 qui est
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté le
rectifié
retiré le
554 rectifié qui est
pour
contre AB
tion non adopté le 590 rectifié de la
commiss 790 rectifié qui est
pour
contre abstention
adoptétis le 156 est
satisfait retiré parce que satisfait
817 amendement du Gouvernement qui est
pour contre abstention adopté
rectifié
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté le
623 pour
contre abstention il a été retiré juste
avant de ne pas être
adopté je mets au voix l'article 16 B A
qui est pour
contre abstention il est
adopté amendement
818 article additionnel après l'article
16 B a Monsieur le Ministre amendement
présenté par le
gouvernement additionnel qui sont
des des
corrections pour remédier à une
inégalité de traitement résultant
d'uneission à vol du législateur
concernant la question de la pénbilité
en matière de retraite pour les
ressortissants agricoles salariés et non
salariés des départements du orin et du
Barin et de la
Moselle la VO la loi qui a été votée av
oublié etis de de régler ce problème
pour ces départements dont on sait qu'il
y a sur le domaine social et en
particulier sur les retraite des comment
dirais-je un cadre
spécifique
merci monsieur le rapporteur favorable
je mets au voix cet amendement 818 pour
contre abstention il est adopté le 819
monsieur le ministre
toujours alors ça c'est un amendement du
Gouvernement
819 qui est un amendement de
simplification il aurait pu être
présenté par les sénateurs ici présents
qui va permettre de créer un nouveau
titre emploi le titre emploi service
agricole TESA TESA ouais qui va
permettre aux entreprises d'accomplir
toutes les déclarations et formalités
lié à l'emploi de salariés en CDD et
dans la limite de 5 CDI voilà donc c'est
vraiment on simplifie et on crée un
titre emploi service agricole je pense
que c'est une bonne mesure et donc je
vous invite à à voter cet amendement 819
du gouvernement merci monsieur le
rapporteur jure que nous nous n'aurions
pas pu présenter parce que article 40
mais très favorable je mets donc au voix
cette amendement 819 du gouvernement
pour contre abstention il est
adopté l'amendement 157 monsieur l'abbé
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues alors que les
Chambres d'ôes et table d'ôes qui
constituent l'accueil touristique sont
réputé comme activité agricole l'accueil
social ne l'est pas une ferme est un
lieu d'accueil social privilégié
permettant de relier les personnes en
réinsertion à la terre à la production
sur le long terme le fait de récolter
les fruits de son travail d'évoluer dans
de grands espaces de fréquenter des
agriculteurs dont les difficultés sont
également importantes permet d'apporter
une certaine stabilité cela est
aujourd'hui pratiqué et reconnu
d'ailleurs des associations de
développement agricole et rural ont
signé une convention avec le ministère
de la Justice pour développer les
accueils de jeunes mineurs à la ferme il
serait donc grand temps de reconnaître
l'accueil social comme activité agricole
pour en définir les modalités nous
demandons qu'un rapport soit remis au
Parlement parce que nous n'avions pas
d'autre moyen que le rapport notre
amendement vise donc à rétablir
l'article de loi le proposant je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
s'il vous plaîtoui monsieur le Président
jurisprudence Raoul aucun rapport
supplémentaire en commission donc
l'Assemblée avait présenté en première
lecture cet amendement la commission l'a
a mis un avis défavorable à retirer vous
présentez l'amendement je suis au regret
de vous donner un avis
défavorable sagesse du Sénat et de la
Commission et du rapporteur et donc du
ministre
monsieur selon les bonnes pratiques de
cette assemblée je vais le retirer en
souhaitant vivement monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur que pour la monsieur le
ministre évidemment que pour la seconde
lecture nous puissions intégrer cette
cet élément qui est drôlement drôlement
important tout le monde en est d'accord
donc monsieur le ministre juste sur
cette question je vaux pas aller audà
rapidement reconnaître cette partie
sociale d'une activité agricole à partir
du moment où elle est d'insertion où
elle est à l' demande en particulier de
la justice pour des jeunes dans
l'insertion par le travail c'est pas
dans le domaine de l'agriculture c'est
l'activité agricole est un outil et un
moyen d'insertion mais reconnaître à
l'agriculture une dimension sociale
serait changer le caractère agricole de
l'activité de base donc c'est plus
compliqué qu'on ne le croit même si je
comprends que derrière il y a des
intentions qui sont tout à fait justes
en tout cas mais à partir du moment où
il y a une activité d'insertion dans le
cadre de l'agriculture et bien cette
activité d'insertion relève d'une
démarche sociale démarche judiciaire
d'insertion des jeunes et c'est vrai que
c'est difficile à ce momentl de refaire
basculer l'agriculteur parce que là on
parle bien d'agriculteur dans un domaine
qui est hors le domaine de l'agriculture
en tout cas dans une loi agricole ça
serait
difficile merci donc l'article 16 bis
reste
supprimé le l'amendement 158 donc vous
avez à nouveau la parole monsieur
l'abbé je vous remercie alors autre
activité agricole la métanisation comme
solution aux excédents azotés de
l'élevage industriel soyons clair c'est
techniquement illusoire et c'est
politiquement problématique illusoire
techniquement car de faible efficacité
énergétique supposant une source de
carbone complémentaire n'éliminant pas
l'azote qui est simplement minéralisé et
dont le digestat est sensible à gérer le
soutien à la méthanisation pour les
effluant d'élevage est une réponse
courttermiste au problèmes de production
intensive voire même l'encourage la
méanisation peut avoir un intérêt et
c'est démontré dans le cadre de démarche
territorialisé et inclusive où les
sous-produits des uns sont les
ressources des autres seulle
l'utilisation de culture intermédiaire
ou de déchets doit être envisager c'est
ce que nous proposons au travers de cet
amendement là encore la méthanisation
oui mais la méthanisation mesuré merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur du
gouvernement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre rapidement monsieur
l'abbé sur cette question de la
méthanisation le fait que vous fermiez
complètement les par la loi la le fait
que on ne peut utiliser dans les
installations de métanisation que les
déchets alors les déchets vous savez
c'est vaste hein et les cultures
intermédiaires sachant qu'il peut y
avoir à un moment ou un autre des
besoins d'utiliser des pailles et du
carbone pas forcément prévu en terme de
culture intermédiaire mais qui viennent
ajuster le fonctionnement du méthanisur
mettre dans la loi qu'on ne peut rien
mettre d'autre que les cultures
intermédiaires ou les déchets ça va
compliquer les choses je rappelle qu'il
y a un rapport de laadème ça c'est très
important qu'on le sache qui laisse
entrevoir en terme de potentiel pour la
métanisation agricole et matière
organique de manière générale avec les
collectivités locales qui laisse
percevoir qu'on pourrait atteindre 40 %
de la consommation de gaz actuel en
France quand on voit ce qui se passe
hein les problèmes d'approvisionnement
toutes les discussions qu' ont lieu
l'enjeu de la méthanisation est
extrêmement important dans le plan Emma
qu'on a présenté énergie méthane
azote et agriculture non c'était je ne
sais plus Emma énergie
métaléisation et autonomie azote parce
qu'il y avait la question d'autonomie on
a bien précisé que le cadre
gouvernemental c'était des cultures
intermédiaires c'estàd qu'on voulait pas
de concurrence entre la production de
culture alimentaire ou fourragère pour
les animaux avec la méthanisation donc
c'est fait c'est précisé le mettre dans
la loi et se retrouver complètement
coincé si à un moment ou un autre il a
besoin de s'ajuster ça serait vraiment
quelque chose de trop lourd donc moi je
suis pas favorable à cet amendement même
si je comprends l'esprit l'esprit il est
déjà inscrit dans les choix que nous
avons fait dans la mise en place du plan
sur la
méthanisation je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 158 qui est
pour contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement rectifié Monsieur
Charles rev
oui monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
le
Ministre chers collègues c'est un
amendement de bon sens la vente sur le
territoire national de produits
alimentaires ayant utilisé pour la
production la conservation la
transformation des substances ou des
pratiques prohibées en France est
interdite le non respect de ces
dispositions peut être sanctionné d'une
amende de 1000 € l'explication c'est que
la France et d'une certaine façon le
comprendre dans sa volonté de protéger
nos concitoyens dans le domaine
alimentaire en terme d'hygiène ou
sanitaire c'est doté de lois règlement
très contraignants il paraît logique
dans un souci de transparence que ces
dispositions soient respectées tant pour
les productions intérieures que pour les
importations merci monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
jeis demander à Monsieur revet de le
retirer sinon avis défavorable parce que
là encore et je veux pas chaque fois
dire la même chose mais on peut être
d'accord sur sur ce que vous dites mais
il me semble que la mise en œuvre que
vous proposez elle est elle est trop
complexe donc comment on peut on
pourrait arriver à régler cela moi je je
n'ai pas je peux pas donner d'arguments
et on a travaillé les services du Sénat
ont travaillé on n pas trouvé la
possibilité donc je vous mets un retrait
sinon avis défavorable à moins que le
ministre me convaincre de de
l'inverse monsieur le ministre
voulez-vous convaincre le rapporteur non
la la vraie question qui est posée
monsieur rev par votre amendement je le
conçois tout à fait c'est qu'on
interdirait donc l'importation de
produits qui ne respecteraiit pas les
mêmes normes sanitaires que celles qu'on
applique en France sauf que c'est comme
pour l'étiquetage c'est des règl c'est
des règlements et c'est des règles
européennes qui s'appliquent vous savez
bien qu'on est dans un marché européen
et donc la liberté de circulation des
hommes et des marchandises fait que sur
ces questions-là on ne peut pas
interdire l'utilisation ou l'importation
de produits qui respecteraient pas
exactement les mêmes normes que chez
nous ce qui pose comme question à
l'échelle européenne ce qu'on appelle la
reconnaissance mutuelle des différentes
pratiques à l'échelle européenne et ce
qui pose au niveau international le
cadre des échanges internationaux dans
lequel les règles sanitaires sont
discutés et négociés au niveau de l'OMC
règles sanitaires d'ailleurs qui sont
dans le non tarifffaire ce qui y a de
plus difficile à maîtriser regardez ce
qui s'est passé juste un exemple hein
avec euh
l'embargo enfin la fin des exportations
de cochons et de porc en Russie du jour
au lendemain sur une peste porcine qui
était liée à des sang Guill en Lettonie
tout a été fermé et il y a d'ailleurs de
la part de l'Europe ce qui n'était pas
forcément ce que nous souhaitions mais
l'Europe a déposé un panel à l'échelle
de l'OMC sur cette question donc on est
vraiment là dans des règlements avec des
accords internationaux et comme vous le
savez les accords internationaux
s'appliquent à la législation nationale
et donc et pour ce qui est du règlement
européen très clairement on peut pas
aller jusqu'à interdire ça c'est pas
possible par contre ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse c'est un ne pas surtransposer
débat qu'on a eu déjà à plusieurs
reprises et deux surtout qu'on fasse
avancer ce qu'on appelle les
reconnaissances mutuelles c'est-à-dire
que ce qui est reconnu dans un pays
européen je parle he doit être reconnu
dans un autre voilà ça c'est le vrai
sujet merci Monsieur revet
oui monsieur le ministre je vais prendre
un exemple très très simple puisque j'ai
eu moi-même en d'autres temps intervenir
c'est l'utilisation des
anabolisants j'ai eu à intervenir dessus
puisque j'étais le rapporteur j'étais
censé soutenir le gouvernement j'avais
pas je souhaitais pas rapporter comme le
gouvernement me le demandait
c'est-à-dire la suppression
d'utilisation d'anabolisant naturel
français en France et donc ça a été pris
par décret monsieur le ministre le
problème auquel on est confronté
aujourd'hui c'est que la même année on a
interdit en France l'utilisation
d'anabolisant naturel français les
États-Unis ont autoriser l'utilisation
de ces abisant aux États-Unis et
Monsieur le Ministre peut-être vous
allez pouvoir me répondre mais il semble
que l'Europe et je comprends
bien le problème que ça pose vient
d'autoriser l'importation en Europe de
40000 tonnes de viande des
États-Unis
bien alors ceci étant parce qu'on
pourrait prendre des exemples multiples
notamment avec les OGM ou autres alors
moi je comprends bien qu'on veuille être
parfait chez nous mais si on laisse
rentrer des produits qui utiliseent des
des procédés ou des produits interdits
en France qu'est-ce qu'on fait bientôt
on pourra plus rien faire en France mais
on laissera rentrer tous les produits
fait n'importe comment à l'étranger
alors monsieur le ministre je voudrais
bien que vous me donniez peut-être vous
allez avoir me apporter une réponse sur
ces 40000 tonnes et j'en seraai très
heureux mais ça empêche pas que le
problème il est général et qu'il faudra
bien qu'un jour on se pense sur cette
situation en France si on veut pas
fermer toutes les productions en
France donc votre amendement est
retiré voilà monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
sénateur sur la question du Canada les
40000 tonnes c'est l'accord qui a été
passé entre l'Europe et le Canada pas
avec les États-Unis puisque puisque la
question des États-Unis aujourd'hui
c'est le débat qui qui est engagé je ne
sais pas combien de temps ça durera mais
il y a pas d'accord signé avec les
États-Unis aujourd'hui sur le Canada les
40000 tonnes autorisé à l'exportation
sur le marché européen par les Canadiens
se feront à la condition qu'une filière
non de de viande non anabolisée soit
mise en place au can Canada ce qui n'est
pas encore le cas aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui tant que ça c'est pas réglé
les normes européennes qui
s'appliqueront et les Canadiens ne
pourront pas exporter de viande sur le
marché européen canadien qui exporte par
contre des viandes anabolisées sur le
marché russe sur tout un tas de marché
au niveau international mais en Europe
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que vous
dites sur est-ce qu'on a laissé faire et
laissé rentrer non c'est la Commission
qui négocie les accords commerciaux et
sur cette question les États avaient été
très clair il ne peut pas y avoir
d'ouverture du marché sur la viande si
il y a des an mobilisants et donc les
Canadiens avaient considéré puisque
c'était du côté de l'Alberta qui voulait
lancer une filière ils ont 3 4 ans avant
d'arriver à avoir une filière non non
anabolisée pour pouvoir exporter de la
viande en Europe mais on n pas cédé
là-dessus de la même manière que sur la
question de des discussions ouvertes sur
les États-Unis les lignes rouges qui ont
été mises portent sur la question des
anabolisants sur les questions
d'utilisation des Javel sur la question
des IGP on a mis un certain nombre de
liges rougge à la commission qui négocie
au nom de T tous les états et on de
l'Europe merci Monsieur bailli
oui moi j'étais cignataire des
amendement de cet amendement proposé par
Charles rev parce que je pensais qu'il
allait dans le bon sens et je crois
qu'il faudra quand même bien qu'on se
penche réellement sur ce si on décide
pour aujourd'hui qu'on se penche sur ce
problème là parce que les agriculteurs
aussi les producteurs quels qu'ils
soient ils comprennent pas finalement
qu'on laisse
importer des des produits alimentaires
qui sont consommés et qu'on a dont on
interdit les procédures chez nous et qui
sont pu être
fait sur des continents encore qui sont
même pas l'Europe qui sont à l'extérieur
et la question que qu'on se pose aussi
ce je sais bien qu'on va pas le régler
on va pas ouvrir le débat aujourd'hui
sur ce problème mais quand on sait que
par exemple nous autres nous devons pas
du tout du tout donner OGM
à nos à à nos animaux pour la production
de coné en même temps on n'est pas du
puis puis on le souscrit pleinement mais
qu'en même temps on sait qu'on a plein
de d'arachides qui arrivent impimportter
qui sont été cultivés avec des OGM alors
il y a quand même bien quelque chose qui
n'est pas clair là-dessus donc il
faudrait bien qu'on se penche réellement
sur ce problème si on l'interdit chez
nous il faut qu'on interdise aussi que
nos ports que nos frontières puissent
laisser rentrer de de de de ces produits
et c'est pour ça c'est moi je pense que
Charl rev le considérera aussi comme moi
un un amendement d'appel pour qu'il a
vraie réflexion sur ce sujet-là dans les
mois qui viennent et que peut-être peut
se servir ce la commission économique
peut prendre ça à la réflexion du moins
c'est ce que je suggère à mon
Président Madame
Blandin amendement de Monsieur revet à
tout la sympathie des écologistes et je
voudrais dire que j'ai bien écouté le
ministre et c'est implacable ce qui dit
chacune des phrases du ministre est
juste
mais les urnes nous ont dit que les
pédales qu'on agite ils ne les entendent
plus que c'est plus efficace sur le
terrain et quand on lit la phrase simple
qui nous est proposé dans cet amendement
celle-là elle parle aux gens elle est du
bon sens si c'est interdit en France on
va quand même pas accepter que ça rentre
ou ne pas punir ceux qui le vendent moi
sur les marchés dans le nordpcala je
peux vous emmener voir tous les produits
prohibés qui sont à vendre pour
l'élevage et qui passent par la Belgique
dans les Alpes Maritimes j'ai suivi des
fraises contaminées aux pesticides
interdites en France retiré de la vente
parti en Italie transformé en confiture
revenu par la France frontiè et en vente
sur nos marchés ça c'est du bon sens ça
les gens ils voient tous les jours alors
ce que vous dites avec les aénarques
monsieur le ministre c'est implacable
c'est juste c'est pas contestable sauf
que les gens ne veulent plus suivre ces
règlesl et qu'on a besoin de revenir à
des choses de bon sens donc moi si vous
le gardez je le
vote alors Monsieur R oui non mais
monsieur monsieur le Président c'est un
un amendement d'appel comme l'a dit mon
ami Jard Baili je suis pas là pour mais
mais monsieur le ministre il faut quand
même qu'on se penche là-dessus parce que
pardà l'aspect alimentaire pour la
population il y a la situation
économique de nos agriculteurs il faut
avoir l'esprit alors j'espère qu'on y
reviendra et en attendant je je le
retire monsieur le président merci
Monsieur revet l'amendement est retiré
je vous propose une suspension de séance
de 5 minutes à la demande du
gouvernement
la séance est
reprise amendement
rectifié monsieur
l'abbé n'est pas en séance mais madame
Blandin est
là je suis là et vous pouvez le
considérer comme présenté puisqu'il
s'agit de l'attente des consommateurs et
des citoyens en matière
alimentaire
merci monsieur le
rapporteur pardon favorable faorable
monsieur le
ministre bon là c'est un sujet qu'on a
déjà abordé à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est vrai que pour ce qui est de la
loi on pense quein pas qu'on pense mais
c'est c'est les précisions que vous
faites sur la un plan territorial c'est
ça le schéma alimentaire c'est pas du
domaine de la loi parce Queen fait les
collectivités locales ont un libre
arbitre et euh on libre gestion et on ne
pourrait pas et on ne peut pas leur
imposer un plan territorial sur
l'alimentation donc c'est c'est la seule
raison qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut
pas après vérification parce que j'en
avais déjà débattu avec un certain
nombre de de collègues à l'Assemblée
qu'on peut pas donner un avis favorable
comme l'a dit j'imagine l'avis favorable
du rapporteur c'est sur l'esprit le
principe il y a aucun problème mais il y
a une libre administration des des
collectivités territoriales qui ne peut
pas être mise en cause sur un sujet
comme
celui-là bien donc l'avis est favorable
de la commission et l' viis est
défavorable du gouvernement vous
demandez la parole madame Blandin vous
l'avez juste pour le dire que nous le
maintenons il s'agit absolument pas de
de de prendre date sur les collectivités
ce sont au contraire des collectivités
qui nous ont demandé de porter ce texte
pour les sécuriser et puis pour faire
exemplarité j'insisterai sur la dernière
phrase ils peuvent mobiliser ils peuvent
également donc on est dans le le Conseil
on n'est pas dans l'obligation comme on
fait pour un Scott ou un PLU il est hors
de question d'imposer à tout le monde de
se mettre au travail demain mais je peux
vous dire que là où ça se fait ça
fonctionne très bien et surtout surtout
ça crée du dialogue entre les
producteurs les distributeurs les
consommateurs les cantines ça crée de
l'emploi ça structure les filières ça
sécurise les
producteurs bien je vais mettre au voix
cette amendement 187 rectifié qui est
pour
contre abstention il est adopté et je
mets au voix l'article 17
pour contre abstention il est
adopté la 454 rectifier l'amendement 454
n'est pas
défendu le 469 madame fer 469 rectifié
bis merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
conformément préconisation de la mission
commune d'information sur la filière
viande en France et en Europe il
convient d'étudier la mise en place
d'information à destination du
consommateur l'abattage avec ou sans
étourdissement de l'animal devrait
pouvoir être connu au moment de l'achat
d'un
produit merci monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur le Président euh avis
défavorable bon c'est un rapport mais
au-delà du du rapport auquel on met un
avis défavorable par principe c'est une
idée qui était contenue dans le rapport
viande qui avait été pr par la Mission
viande qui avait été présentée au Sénat
mais ce sont des règles européennes donc
il me semble pas qu'on puiss donner un
avis favorable ça dépend ça dépend pas
de
nous monsieur le
ministre bon j'étais ce matin dans la
Sarte dans une che un gros industriel de
l'agroalimentaire qui est qui a aussi
une une filiale traiteur et qui sur tous
les plats cuisinés qui sont issu de sa
filiale indique
né
élevé abattu et transformé en
France ça fait partie du principe qu'on
a mis en place avec viande de France
estce qu'il faudrait généraliser et
c'est ce qu'il faudrait généraliser mais
pour généraliser ce principe je vous le
dis pour qu'il soit applicable c'est du
domaine réglementaire enfin
réglementaire et législatif européen
l'étiquetage des produits et du domaine
législatif et à l'échelle européenne
toute démarche volontaire et la France
est en pointe là-dessus et ces produits
d'ailleurs commence à avoir un vrai écho
par que les consommateurs ont envie
d'être rassurés après je vais pas y
revenir les affaires qui ont concerné un
certain nombre de lasagne il y a
quelques temps donc on est dans une
démarche volontaire si on veut passer
une démarche obligatoire c'est la
législation européenne sinon n'importe
quel industriel pourra contester et vous
ne pourrez pas la liqué le débat à
l'échelle européenne a été lancé il
n'est pas facile parce qu'il y a des
grands industriels à l'échelle
européenne qui achèent des produits à à
l'échelle de l'Europe voire quelquefois
à l'échelle internationale et qui ne
souhait pas justement rentrer dans un
étiquetage qui oblige à mettre en place
une traçabilité issue des élevages de
chacun des
pays ensuite dans cet amendement madame
joyot il y a la question de l'abattage
lui-même et si j'ai bien compris en
fonction du mode d'abattage donc je vois
à quoi on fait référence sujet là aussi
qui est extrêmement délicat d'abord il
est réglementé à l'échelle européenne il
y a des règles et des dérogations à
l'échelle européenne qui s'applique
ensuite à chacun des pays sujet
éminemment compliqué qui consiste aussi
si on se laisse aller à faire des
stigmatisation sur des produits avec
derrière des enjeux qui dépassent la
seule question agricole donc sur cette
et en fonction de ces deux principes à
la fois l'étiquetage et la question la
question d'abattage rituel qui sont du
domaine européen je souhaite indiquer
que le gouvernant n'est pas favorable à
cet amendement merci Madame ferra
ou
oui merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
envie de vous prendre un autre exemple
c'est celui qui touche les œufs par
exemple le code 3 c'est en cage le code
2 c'est au sol le code 1 c'est en
pleinire et le code zé c'est biologique
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'essaierait pas
de calquer ce qui se passe pour les œufs
et et on a on s'est aperçu que depuis le
consommateur qui est sensible à cette à
cet étiquetage est beaucoup plus présent
pour acheter les œufs pourquoi est-ce
qu'on ne se calerait pas sur ce qui se
passe à ce niveau-là je vous ai pris cet
exemple il y en a sans doute bien
d'autres pour faire la même chose ou
tout au moins quelque chose d'approchant
au niveau de la viande je n'ai pas
besoin de vous dire que les
consommateurs sont traumatisés depuis
quelques mois par les affaires que que
nous venons de
madame
landandin en soutien à cet amendement
parce que contrairement à ce qui a été
évoqué dans la réponse il s'agit pas de
produit en France ou pas produit en
France il ne s'agit pas non plus des
modes d'abattage il s'agit des
conditions d'élevage et je le répète il
y a des gens qui sont non végétariens
qui consomment de la viande mais qui ont
pas envie d'être moralement des bourreau
à l'image de ce qu'on voit dans
certaines émissions sur les lieux
concentrationnaires d'élevage avec
mutilation et tout ça ils veulent
simplement avoir le choix et quand ils
ont une escalope dans leur assiette se
dire bah la bestiole elle a quand même
eu une vie à peu près digne et on lui a
pas coupé le bec les pattes et tout ça
on n pas rendu sa vie absolument une
souffrance d'un an avant de passer à
table voilà c'est tout et ce les exemple
des œufs est exemplaire et depuis la
production augmente c'est un soutien aux
éleveurs je vais mettre au voix monsieur
le ministre si vous voulez c'était clair
hein madame Blandin je peux pas vous
laisser dire des choses qui sont pas
vraies parce qu'il faut lire
l'amendement dans un délai d'un an à
compté de la pruligation de la présente
loi le Gouvernement remet au Parlement
un rapport étudiant les possibilités
d'introduction d'un étiquetage
obligatoire de la viande ou d'une
préparation contenant de la viande en
fonction du mode d'abattage c'est pas du
mode d'élevage je suis désolé non mais
il a pas le bon amendement ah ben oui
mais là il y a un problème bon donc
c'est pas le sujet est deuxièmement sur
la question des œufs c'est ça vient
comment dirais-je abonder mon argument
puisque cette règle et cette
réglementation est aujourd'hui
européenne et troisème point sur la
question du bien-être animal je rappelle
que cette loi pour la première fois
indique dans les objectifs à poursuivre
dans la politique agricole le bien-être
animal et que le bien-être animal
maintenant a des règlements européens
qui définissent des cadre extrêmement
strict qui pose d'ailleurs suffisamment
de problèm dans la mise au norme des
bâtiments pour les éleveurs pour faire
en sorte qu'on ne soit plus dans les
débat où on laisse penser qu'on aurait
dans la production des situations et des
conditions de production qui soient cell
qu'on n'a pu connaître il y a 20 30 ans
mais qui ne sont plus du tout
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du
jour je mets au voix cet amendement 469
rectifié bis
pour pour je continue le vote il est
lancé pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté
vous vouliez dire quelque chose madame
Blandin je vous prie d'excuser la
confusion que je sème je m'étais exprimé
sur le 454 mais je m'aperçois que
l'auteur même de l'amendement n'a pas vu
disparaître son 454
voilà d'accord il est tombé ni madame
joanau ni madame Goulet ni monsieur
deraille nétant présent l'amendement est
tombé
l'amendement donc n'est pas adopté le
rectifié madame
Bor merci monsieur le Président je lis
simplement la proposition d'amendement
et puis l'argumentaire je vais le
raccourcir une information et une
éducation à l'alimentation sont dispensé
dans les écoles dans le cas des
enseignements ou du projet éducatif
territorial prévu à l'article L
551 1-1 pardon ces séances peuvent
s'appuyer sur l'éducation sensorielle et
nutritionnelle je pense que chacun de
nous est conscient que dans notre pays
il y a un certain nombre de problèmes
d'alimentation même si le le modèle
français a été adopté
comme patrimonial et donc supposé être
excellent mais il y a tout de même dans
notre pays un certain nombre de
problèmes qui se posent quant à
l'alimentation
et en particulier près d'un enfant sur 6
est en surpoids voire obèse et donc ça
pourrait être une excellente mesure que
de proposer soit sous forme ludique et
pourquoi pas dans l'aménagement des
temps du temps scolaire de favoriser
pour les enfants euh les informations à
une alimentation de qualité saine et
équilibrée et je pense que ça donnerait
un peu de corps à un programme européen
dont on ne parle pas beaucoup en France
mais qui consiste à distribuer des
fruits à la récrée du matin ou du lait
et nous voilà revenu au temps de Pierre
mandz France au temps de notre jeunesse
mais je pense que cela aiderait
effectivement à faire prendre conscience
aux enfants que leur alimentation est
importante qu'elle doit être équilibrée
et je pense qu'à l'école ça pourrait
être un élément important
d'éducation merci monsieur le
rapporteur
favorable je mets au voix cet amendement
qui est pour contre abstention il est
adopté l'amendement 335 rectifié
bis monsieur Cardou
peut-être il est défendu monsieur le
rapporteur
avis défavorable avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre mê aVIS Avis déf je
mets au vois qui est pour contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté
695 madame
bouretèg l'objectif de cet amendement
est de rendre obligatoire
l'identification des caméidé en France
aujourd'hui selon les estimations entre
10000 environ 10000 camélidé circulent
sur le territoire français et ce nombre
est en constante augmentation jusqu'à
présent leur identification est
facultative et aucun suivi de leur
mouvement à l'intérieur du pays n'est en
vigueur il conviendrait donc
d'établir des mesures en particulier
pour des raisons sanitaires mettre en
place une série de réformes que je je
vous passe pour arriver à identifier ces
animaux et je pense qu'il serait
important de confier la gestion de cette
identification à une entité qui gère
déjà celle des chevaux le cire de
l'Institut français du cheval et de
l'édication l'équitation en tant que
maître d'œuvre de l'identification équin
qui maîtrise déjà la problématique de la
commande des transpondeurs ou de boutons
auriculaires l'impression de la
d'identité la carte de propriété la
connexion avec les vétérinaires
identificateur de plus l'IFCE où j'ai
l'honneur de siéger pour représenter le
Sénat gère la connexion avec les
vétérinaires et les procédures de
commande des
transondeurs cet amendement propose donc
de lui confier la gestion de
l'identification des camélidés en
France Merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
favorable je mets au voix pour
contre abstention adopté
694 vous gardez la parole madame
Bour le amendement vise à permettre au
ministre de l'Agriculture de désigner
des centres nationaux de référence en
matière de bien-être animal qui auront
vocation à apporter une expertise
technique et des innovations dans ce
domaine actuellement règlement européen
du Parlement et du Conseil concernant
les contrôles officiels est en cours de
fin tion son objectif est d'harmoniser
l'application de l'ensemble des règles
communautaires par les États-membres ce
futur règlement donnera à la commission
la possibilité de désigner des centres
de référence de l'Union européenne pour
le bien-être des animaux cette notion de
centre de référence européen en matière
de bien-être des animaux fait éch à la
notion de centre collaborateur de
l'Office mondial de la santé animale
dans le dispositif législatif français
relatif à la protection des animaux il
conviendrait d'introduire par ordonnance
la notion de centre de référence en
bien-être des animaux la désignation
d'un ou plusieurs centres apporterait
une légitimité aux actions de centre de
recherche actuelle et permettrait
également de faciliter la désignation de
centre officiel français en tant que
centre de référence communautaire les
centres de référence apporteront une
expertise technique et contribueront à
la diffusion des résultats de la
recherche et des innovation
technique merci monsieur le rapporteur
favorable
je mets au voix donc cet amendement
soutenu activement
694 pour contre abstention il est adopté
le 820 monsieur le ministre
oui le 820 est un amendement du
Gouvernement qui
porteement des contrôles sur l'âge et
l'origine des animaux en particulier
dans pas en particulier de manière
spécifique sur les équidés vous savez et
vous en avez entendu parler l'affaire
des lasagnes euh de cheval des sujets
d'ailleurs ensuite sur un certain nombre
d'animaux qui avaient été mis en pension
et qui ont disparu ensuite nécessite
qu'on soit mieux organisé et qu'on
contrôle mieux les équider c'est
l'objectif de cet amendement que je vous
invite à voter parce qu'on a besoin là
de progresser dans la manière dont on
gère l'ensemble des animaux et dans en
parti enfin les ensembles des animaux
équidé parce que on a constaté au vu des
actualités que j'aiévoqué qu'il y avait
là des manquements sur lesquels il faut
qu'on revienne c'est l'objectif de cet
amendement monsieur le rapporteuris
favorable monsieur le Unis favorable je
mets au voix cet amendement du
Gouvernement pour contre abstention
adopté sur l'article 18 discussion
commune amendement 159 monsieur
laabé
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues au préalable je
vais réaffirmer notre attachement au
pastoralisme et à son maintien et son
développement cette nouvelle disposition
vise explicitement le loup et mettrait
les fédérations de chasse en
responsabilité dans les opérations de
tir de prélèvement de loup rappelons que
la gestion du loup en France est
encadrée par le plan national loup
2013-207 dont les modalités sont
débattues par une instance spécifique
groupe national loup qui regroupe les
acteurs concernés les dérogations à la
protection du loup et les tirs de
prélèvement sont encadrés par les agents
de
l'ONCFS selon un protocole établi par
arrêté ministériel ces disposition
précise déjà que des chasseurs peuvent
sous certaines conditions strictes
notamment de formation préalable être
nominativement associé aux opérations de
tir une application plus large des
fédération départementale n'est donc ni
ni nécessaire ni souhaitable elle
entrerait de plus en contradiction avec
les dispositions en vigueur qui
indiquent que les dérogations à la
protection de cette espèce demeurent
strictement encadré et sont nominatives
conformément aux engagements européens
de la France pour cette
espèce merci Monsieur Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues donc
l'amendement que nous vous proposons
l'article 18 va tout à fait à l'encontre
de ce que vient d'exposer notre collègue
de la BA on ne peut pas demander aux
chasseurs d'être responsable d'un
certain nombre de dégâts d'un certain
nombre de surpopulation d'animaux sur
les territoires sur lesquels il chasse
et d'un autre côté leur déer la la
possibilité sous contrôle d'effectuer
des tirs de régulation alors ce que j'ai
entendu dans votre bouche on en a eu
l'exemple depuis quelques années
c'est-à-dire que les tirs de loup
étaient extrêmement cadrés fait par des
agents des agents de
l'ONCFS avec une formation préalable
pour certains chasseurs on a vu le
résultat c'est-à-dire qu' une grogne qui
monte de tous les côtés de tous les
bergers avec des troupeaux qui sont
décimés dans différents endroits donc je
pense que la logique d'associer les
fédérations des chasseurs qui sont
parfaitement structurés parfaitement
organisés avec des réseaux dans
l'ensemble de leur département en
s'appuyant sur les associations de
chasseagré pour effectuer ces tirs de
régulation me semble tout à fait logique
et donc dans cet esprit et bien nous
souhaitons simplement pour bien préciser
le rôle que peuvent avoir les
fédérations dans ce domaine ajouter
après l'AR 35 en collaboration avec
leurs adhérents de manière à laisser la
responsabilité aux fédérations sous
contrôle évidemment des DDT et de
l'administration de déléguer une partie
de ces tir de pralivement à des
adhérents préalivement préalablement
désignés et
encadré merci le suivant 571 CIT pas
défendu alors monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur le monsieur le le Président
nous allons nous avons eu un long débat
sur le loup la semaine dernière nous
avons considéré que l'article 18 bis
était ce que nous avons rajouté que j'ai
rédigé que la Commission a adopté la
quasi unanimité considérée comme le loup
donc moi je suis sur le loup donc je
suis défavorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur l'abbé de supprimer les
alignéats 34 35 nous voulons que les
fédérations de chasse soient des acteurs
et je je dirais à Monsieur Cardou que
votre amendement est totalement
satisfait mais puisquon met les
fédérations de chasse il est satisfait
alors que l'on rajoute en collaboration
avec leurs adhérents ça rajoute pas un
peu les fédérations de chasse c'est je
considère qu'il est
satisfait nous y reviendrons dans 10
amendements monsieur le ministre après
monsieur le ministre bon oui c'est vrai
qu'on a eu un long débat là on rentre
dans les dans les dans les enjeux
spécifiques cet amendement sur les
chasseurs dans le plan loup a été
introduit à la demande du ministre que
je
suis parce que jusquel les louftiers
l'organisation qui était celle qui
prévalait faisait que on faisait des
prélèvements longtemps après les
attaques et que souvent d'ailleurs ça
tombait sur des loups j'ai pas fait le
tri he je sais pas mais qui était pas
forcément directement responsable de
l'attaque donc il y a un problème de
moral effectivement que mon
Collin que deuxièmement on mettait du
temps et qu'on faisait venir des gens
qui surtout n'étaient pas forcément en
mesure de connaître le terrain ce qui
faisait qu'on avait une mauvaise
adéquation entre la nécessité de
prélever et de dissuader et celle qui
était effectivement misise en œuvre donc
ça c'est un enjeu qui a été décidé dans
le cadre du Plan loup et qui met les
chasseurs en particulier ceux qui
connaissent au travers de leurs
associations de chasse en disponibilité
pour pouvoir assurer ses prélèvements
rapidement et de manière efficace donc
je là je souhaite vraiment pas qu'on
revienne là-dessus je rappelle que le
plan Lou a été élaboré avec l'ensemble
des représentants de l'élevage des de
des associations environnementales des
professionnels euh de du ministère de
l'Environnement et du ministère de
l'Agriculture si on revient là-dessus là
on remet en cause un plan qui déjà dans
son application a modifié les choses
mais n'est pas encore suffisamment
efficace mais on ne peut pas après un
accord aussi large qui a été celui
obtenu dans le plan loup revenir au
travers d'un moment dans la loi sur ce
qui a été fait donc la question de la
place des chasseurs est taée ils sont
effectivement comme l'a dit le
rapporteur directement lié alors après
renforcer le lien bon c'est pas c'est à
mon avis satisfait dans ce qui existe
aujourd'hui donc je souhaite qu'on en
reste là sur cette question en tout
cas merci Monsieur
Cardou
oui monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je prends acte de vos
explications mais vous savez c'était
simplement euh vous avez tous compris
nous avons tous compris que c'est un
sujet passionnel que c'est un sujet
passionnel qui n'est pas clos encore et
que dans le casadre de ce que nous
venons de dire nous avons toujours la
crainte des recours et de l'entrave à
l'exercice des pr à l'exercice du droit
de prélèvement qui serait confié au
chasseur donc voilà pourquoi euh par
sécurité nous souhaitions que dans le
texte soit inclus euh que les adhérents
des fédérations des chasseurs y sont
associés bon je prends acte de vos
explications euh si un jour euh par
malheur euh des associations font des
recours contre les actions des
fédérations et bien je pense que nous
aurons la sagesse de mettre en avant les
propos que vous avez tenus monsieur le
ministre et monsieur le rapporteur lors
du débat au
Sénat bien merci mais l'amendement est
maintenu retiré merci et donc je mets au
voix l'amendement
159 qui est pour
contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté
l'amendement 11 rectifié sexise monsieur
Mirassou merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission des affaires économiques a
modifié l'article 18 afin de limiter la
respabilité des chasseurs sur le plan
sanitaire aux espèces de gibiers dont la
chasse est autorisée ce qui paraît à peu
près évident et donc par cohérence avec
ces modifications il convient de
corriger la disposition prévoyant que le
schéma départemental de gestion
synergétique comprennent obligatoirement
la disposition permettant de surveiller
et de prévenir la diffusion des dangers
sanitaires entre les animaux sauvages
les les animaux domestiques et l'homme
il faut bien entendu et c'est l'objet de
l'amendement limit le champ de cette
disposition à la diffusion des dangers
sanitaires entre les espèces de gibier
les animaux domestique et l'homme pour
ne pas imputer au chasseurs une
responsabilité qui ne serait pas
laaleure s'agissant des animaux sauvages
qui ne seraient pas des
Gier merci amendement identique 337
rectifié TER monsieur Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je seraai
extrêmement bref puisque nous avons
repris les mêmes termes que notre
collègue Mirassou avec les arguments
tout à fait identiques je crois que on a
toujours des débats contradictoires on
peut pas tout demander aux chasseurs et
on peut pas les rendre responsables de
l'état sanitaire d'espèces don
lesquelles ils n'ont pas le droit de
chasse donc ça me paraît qui soit
responsable des espèces gibiers oui pour
le reste non donc on est tout à fait
dans ce
sens-là merci monsieur le rapporteur ces
deux amendements identiques parce qu'il
a été rectifié monsieur le ministre même
avis je mets au voix ces deux
amendements identiques
pour
contre
abstention unanimité je mets au voix
l'article
pour contre abstention l'article 18 est
adopté amendement 807 monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez de la oui c'est un
amendement j'allais dire de de bon sens
de bon sens Payson c'est dans les
garanties je ne compris pas qu'on puisse
donner une garantie de 2 ans pour un
chien ou pour un chat donc
voilà bah oui monsieur le
ministre
G on est c'est vrai que sur sur les
animaux être sensible c'est dans le Code
Rural ce qui avait été fait dans la loi
consommation pour des garanties 2 ans ça
concerne plutôt les cf ti les biens les
réfrigérateurs tout ce qu'on peut
acheter c'est vrai que d'avoir la même
règle pour des animaux qui sont des
êtres sensibles ne nous paraît pas
exactement relevé du même sujet donc
sommes favorables à cet
amendement
favorable je mets au voix qui est pour
contre abstention
adopté discussion
commune madame ferra pour le 451
rectifiebis merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'Union Professionnelle des pédicure
etquin qui représente cette profession
est dans la demande d'une reconnaissance
et d'un cadre légal pour éviter une
dérive des pratique par manque de
formation professionnelle cette
profession au même titre que la
profession de parur bovin reconnu et
identifié l'article l2433 du code rural
doit en effet être distingué de la
profession de maréchal ferrant car le
pédicure équin ne recourt pas à la
ferrure mais seulement au parage du pied
des
équidés ceci répond à une évolution
profonde de la filière cheval et à la
demande de plus en plus forte des
propriétaires de chevaux et d'un nombre
croissant de centre équestr il y a une
pénurie de marécha Ferran en France 1500
maréchau Ferran pour 1 million d'équidés
recensés en France 2500 en
Grande-Bretagne pour des cheptel de
taille comparable 3000 en Allemagne pour
des ch elle également de taille
comparable dans ces pays il y a
également un important développement de
la profession et cet amendement vise à
contribuer et à renforcer la
compétitivité l'emploi et la qualité des
services de la filière équestre en
initiant la reconnaissance réglementaire
d'une nouvelle profession en plein
essort merci monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur le le Président j'ai met un
avis défavorable je ne suis pas
favorable à la création d'une profession
réglementée de pédicure équin euh en
théorie les Mar Chau sont là pour pour
faire cela avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre même
avis sur la
péigure merci l'amendement
741 rectifié n'est pas défendu je mets
donc voit le 451 rectifi B
pour contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté voilà vous avez donc pu suivre la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'agriculture tout de suite 24h Sénat